Und dann gibt's noch ein paar. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Zum letzten Donnerstag in diesem Jahr in einem Monat, in dem an dieser Stelle das läuft, was immer dann passiert, wenn ein letzter Donnerstag im Monat, also fast da ist nämlich, dass der Chaos Computer Club das Studio ändert, entert oder seine Anverwandten, Umkreisfreunde, wie man das so nennen will. Es geht dann immer traditionell um Themen mit Strom und Bits und Bites und den Dingen, die man damit anstellen kann oder die man damit anstellen sollte. Und das ist auch heute das Thema. Es geht um einen auf den ersten Blick etwas sperriges Wort, Technikkompetenzvermittlung könnte man es nennen. Es geht darum, wie man Menschen dazu bringt, sich mit der Technik auseinanderzusetzen, die er mittlerweile unser aller Leben kontrolliert, reguliert, misst, anzeigt und was man da so machen kann. Da sieht es ja möglicherweise nicht so gut aus, wie man das vielleicht denken könnte. Und das wollen wir heute mal genauer besprechen. Natürlich sind dazu auch eure eigenen Geschichten gefragt. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass der ein oder andere von euch Umgang mit dem Lehrkörper, den ich jetzt mal hab, also keiner Lehrer in der Schule, Ausbilder bei der Ausbildung, vielleicht sogar in der Uni oder mit den Eltern, wo ganz klar wird, dass so ein bestimmtes Gefälle im Wissen und im Umgang mit Technik vorhanden ist. Und wenn ihr sozusagen einen derart inkompetenten oder kompetenten Lehrkörper habt und darüber eine Geschichte erzählen wollt, könnt ihr euch gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. So, angekündigt war ja, wie gesagt, dass dann Leute hier sind von dieser Vereinigung oder dem Umfeld. Und das sind heute wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich viele. Ich glaube, so voll hatte das Studio noch nie. Und wir fangen mal an von links nach rechts. Ich begrüße ganz herzlich die Fiona. Hallo, guten Abend.
Hi, guten Abend.
Dann begrüße ich den Daniel Seitz. Hallo, guten Abend. Dann begrüße ich die Maria Reimer.
Hallo.
Und den Leander.
Und den Zebas.
Schönen guten Abend zusammen.
Und all diese Leute wollen heute mit uns und euch darüber reden, wie das jetzt eigentlich ist mit diesem, ja manche sagen Technikkompetenz, manche sagen Medienkompetenz und dann können wir vielleicht mal damit anfangen, was genau das eigentlich bedeutet. Aber vielleicht, bevor wir das machen, erklärt ihr erstmal, warum ihr eigentlich hier seid. Fiona, es gibt heute so Projekte, wegen denen seid ihr auf die Liste der Leute gekommen, die heute hier im Studio sind. Das ist bei dir Jugend hackt, aber das ist nicht alles. Warum bist du heute hier? Als wer bist du heute hier?
Genau, ich mache schon seit einigen Jahren, jetzt mittlerweile fast drei Jahre, engagiere ich mich in dem Bereich, ich sage jetzt mal Code Literacy und hoffe, dass ich das nicht den Begriff erklären muss.
Natürlich musst du den Begriff erklären.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen den Begriff, mit dem man etwas weiter Technikkompetenz umfassen kann, wo es nicht nur um Programmieren, also Code Literacy geht, sondern meiner Meinung nach auch um etwas Umfassenderes, eben die Fähigkeit mit technischen Geräten souverän umzugehen und vielleicht auch damit was Kreatives zu erschaffen. Aber genau in dem Bereich engagiere ich mich seit einer Weile und sehe mich ein bisschen als Vermittlerin. Ich bin selber, ich stamme selber eher aus einem Gebiet, so Mathe, Chemie, Physik 5, kenne mich eigentlich gar nicht so gut damit aus, aber habe halt vor drei Jahren angefangen, Programmieren zu lernen und mich mehr mit Technik auseinanderzusetzen und versuche Leute mit verschiedenen Angeboten ebenfalls zu motivieren, etwas in dem Bereich zu machen und zu lernen. Zum Beispiel mit einem Podcast oder mit einem Blog oder so dies und das.
Na, wenn du jetzt schon sagst, wie heißt der Podcast, wie heißt das Buch?
Der Podcast, ja, das muss ich noch eben, heißt Noobcore. Und da setze ich mich mit verschiedenen Experten immer mal hin und frage die eine total dumme Frage, sowas wie was ist eigentlich ein Computer? Und dann erklären sie mir das und dann frage ich, hä? Und dann müssen sie es nochmal erklären, so dass es auch Leute verstehen, so wie ich.
Warte, Moment mal, du machst so eine Art Chaosradio als Podcast? Ist denn das erlaubt?
Nein, das habe ich mir selber ausgedacht.
Na gut, sehr schön, herzlich willkommen. Daniel Seitz, du bist auch bei Jugend hackt dabei, aber du treibst dich vor allen Dingen in seiner ganz bestimmten Subwelt rum. Was genau machst du so? Warum bist du heute hier?
Ich bin Medienpädagoge, das bedeutet, ich beschäftige mich damit, was Menschen mit Medien tun und auch was Medien mit Menschen tun.
Und du gehst bitte dichter ans Mikrofon?
Und ich gehe dichter ans Mikrofon und werde so hoffentlich besser gehört. Sehr gut. Um Gehör geht es meistens, wenn es um Medien geht. Ich finde es jetzt spannend, die nächsten Zeit über Medien, Kompetenzbegriffen und solche Dinge zu diskutieren. Wir als Medienpädagogen tun das sehr viel, sind quasi im Feld unterwegs, arbeiten hauptsächlich mit Jugendlichen und beschäftigen uns mit der Frage, wie kann man insbesondere Jugendliche, aber im Prinzip alle Bürger dazu befähigen, souveränen in einer digitalen Gesellschaft das eigene Leben zu führen. Dazu zählt Technik natürlich ganz stark, die zu verstehen, aber es geht eben auch noch um mehr. Also man kann quasi auch ohne Technik gar nicht mehr in einer mediatisierten Umgebung, also in einer Welt, wo überall Technik vorhanden ist, leben. Und genau das beschäftigt uns gerade ganz viel. Und da versuchen wir Ansätze zu entwickeln. Einer davon ist eben Jugend hackt, wo wir mit Jugendlichen ganz stark auf einer sehr technologienlastigen Ebene arbeiten. Aber es gibt eben noch viel mehr Facetten von Medien, die über das kleine Coden hinausgehen.
Da werden wir uns hier heute noch ausführlich mit beschäftigen. Maria ist auch von Jugend hackt und außerdem?
Und außerdem arbeitet sie halbtags im Bundestag. Genau, mit dem Hut bin ich aber gar nicht hier. Also mein Brotgeld verdiene ich so ein bisschen im Bundestag. Da bin ich wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin von Tabea Rössner. Die ist die grüne medienpolitische Sprecherin. Und in meiner Freizeit organisiere ich dieses schon erwähnte Programm Jugend hackt, zusammen mit Daniel, Fiona und noch ganz vielen anderen Freiwilligen und Ehrenamtlichen. Jugend hackt ist eigentlich so ein bisschen so wie Jugend musiziert oder Jugend forscht, aber für junge Nerds. Also da treffen sich 12 bis 18-Jährige.
Da kommen wir nachher noch zu. Genau, da haben wir die Leander. Hallo Leander. Du bist 12 Jahre?
13.
13, oh mein Gott. Und warst du schon mal bei einem, wo warst du noch mal?
Beim CoderDojo und beim CCC, beim Jugendhackertag auf dem Kongress.
Mit Vorsagen, Cebas. Wer bist du? Was machst du hier?
Ja, schönen guten Abend. Ich bin der Cebas. Ich bin einer derjenigen, die an dem Projekt Chaos macht Schule beteiligt sind, wo der Chaos Computer Club...
Auch du müsstest dich dann als Mikrofon nennen. Was ist mit der Medienkompetenz? Üben wir heute Abend nochmal.
Radio, das kennt doch keiner mehr.
Wir hören alle nur Podcasts.
Ja, aber auch die müssen irgendwie aufgenommen werden. Also da gibt es dieses Projekt, das heißt wie?
Chaos macht Schule, wo der Chaos Computer Club aktiv an Schulen geht und dort Vorträge hält und auf die Gefahren und Umgang mit neuen Medien oder sozialen Netzwerken hält, aber auch andere Themen wie zum Beispiel Datenschutz, sicherer Umgang mit Technik, allerdings auch Lückworkshops anbietet, wo in Schulen kleinere Lötrunden stattfinden, um die Jugendlichen halt an die Technik ran zu führen und die Angst ein Stück weit wegzunehmen.
Okay, das sprechen wir auch noch genauer. Ich möchte am Anfang nämlich sozusagen noch mal ein bisschen über die Motivation sprechen, weil all das, was ihr alle zusammen genommen macht, hat ja damit zu tun, Wissen zu vermitteln. Und dann könnte man ja denken, oder das sind ja auch so Schlagworte, die manchmal in den Medien dann rumkommen, so dieses so, ja wir müssen alle programmieren können oder so. Ist das das Endziel, also wirklich das Endziel, dass wirklich 100 Prozent der Bevölkerung zu ich sage jetzt mal Vollnerds werden müssen, die alle mindestens drei Programmiersprachen fließend beherrschen, einen Chip selber löten können und wissen, wie man eine Überwachungsgeheimgesellschaft auseinandernimmt, oder ist das Ziel eigentlich was anderes?
Aus meiner Perspektive, ich würde sagen nein, darum geht es nicht. Trotzdem muss man dazu auch sagen, es ist ein bisschen wie mit Lesen, man braucht das nicht, um zu überleben, aber es ist verdammt hilfreich und genauso verhält es sich auch mit Programmieren. Aber ich bin mittlerweile eher an dem Punkt, dass ich sage, wir brauchen eine umfassendere Bildung. Und da würde ich auch sagen, das sollten wir versuchen, allen Menschen zugänglich zu machen, noch möglich zu machen. Es finden einfach sehr, sehr viele Entscheidungen statt und Veränderungen in unserem Alltag, die mit Technik zu tun haben. Und ich bin der festen Überzeugung, alle Menschen sollten sich potenziell an diesen Diskussionen beteiligen können oder sie zumindest verstehen.
Okay, und das erreicht man immer in Programmierenden.
Also ich würde auch sagen, nein, braucht nicht jeder, aber trotzdem ist es natürlich wahnsinnig hilfreich, die eigene Welt zu begreifen, wenn man zumindest grundlegende technologische Dinge versteht. Dazu muss man nicht programmieren können. Das glaube ich, auf der Ebene muss man nicht ansetzen, denn ich glaube, das liegt auch einfach nicht jedem. Also so wie jeder in der Schule schon merkt, man kann gut Sprachen, aber nicht gut Mathematik, verhält sich es ja auch mit Programmieren. Also ich nehme mir bei jedem Workshop, den ich mit Jugendlichen mache, vor, ich lerne jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr Programmieren und ich setze mich jedes Mal dazu. Und die Kids sind innerhalb von ein paar Stunden einfach schon so weit, dass ich nicht mehr hinterhergekommen. Also so, ich werde programmieren, nicht mehr lernen. Und ich glaube, das merken ganz viele, dass das nicht der Kern auch ist. Aber natürlich sind Medien und Technologie ein wichtiger Zugang zu Gesellschaft. Also immer mehr findet über Medien statt. Das ist auch ganz wichtig für unsere Demokratie, auch auf welcher Grundlage findet das statt, bewerten zu können. Sind Informationen authentisch? Kann ich den trauen, selber Medien zu gestalten, um zu verstehen, wie das passiert? Also, dass ein gedrucktes Papier, das sich Zeitung nennt, nicht einfach automatisch richtig ist, dass ich ein Foto manipulieren kann, je nachdem, wie ich einen Ausschnitt mache. Das lerne ich am besten nicht, wenn mir jemand erzählt, dass es so ist, sondern indem ich es tue. Also indem ich mich mal vor einem Green Screen stelle und eine komplette Nachrichtensendung durchmoderiere und dazu eigene Trailer produziere, dann habe ich verstanden, ah okay, so funktioniert das also und dann kann ich das viel besser beurteilen. Und jetzt habe ich nur so die klassischen Medien genannt und bei Coder ist es natürlich ähnlich. Also wenn ich da reingucken kann und beurteilen kann, was da passiert, dann hilft mir das natürlich schon, das nochmal stärker zu beurteilen. Schaden tut es auf jeden Fall nicht, wenn ich es lerne, aber ich denke, wir müssen da immer wieder gucken, in welcher Höhe wir ansetzen, weil ich denke, das wäre auch eine Überforderung, wenn wir von allen verlangen, dass man coden können muss.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt, weil es ist, also bis jetzt habe ich gehört, also nein, muss man nicht, aber ja, wäre schon irgendwie geil. Sebastian, hast du da noch irgendwie vielleicht eine genauere Ansage?
Naja, also dass jeder programmieren kann oder programmieren müssen kann, bin ich auch dafür definitiv nein. Allerdings sollte man die Abläufe, die dort stattfinden, schon ein Stück weit nachvollziehen können, da sie unseren Alltag immer mehr beeinflussen und immer mehr Einzug nehmen und auch gewisse Abhängigkeiten davon bestehen und halt auch Gefahren einfach mit sich bringen. Und vielleicht, wenn man ein klein wenig Verständnis für die Abläufe hat, die im Hintergrund stattfinden, sich auch die Gefahren immer wieder vor Augen führt, die mit der Nutzung einhergehen.
Ich bin immer noch sozusagen sehr unentschlossen, ob das jetzt eigentlich Ja oder Nein bedeutet. Die ist es, frage ich also andersherum, es gibt ja dieses, also einfach formuliert ist es ja so, hey, ihr macht irgendwie Sachen, da kann man hinkommen und lernen, so Technik verstehen und das Schlagwort, das ja auch schon viel ist, so Medienkompetenz oder Technikkompetenz. Erste Frage, gibt es da einen Unterschied? Zweite Frage, was ist das eigentlich?
Also Medienkompetenz ist ein sehr alter Begriff, der irgendwann mal von Dieter Backe mit Leben gefüllt wurde sozusagen. Dieter Backe war einer der ersten großen Medienwissenschaftler, auch Medienpraktiker, der hat einen sehr umfassenden Blick auf Medienkompetenzvermittlung gehabt und hat den Begriff so in vier Dimensionen aufgeschlüsselt und dazu sehr Medienkritik, also kritisch mit Medien umzugeben, bewerten zu können, was da passiert. Medienkunde, also ich weiß, was gibt es überhaupt für Medien, was kann ich verwenden? Medienproduktion oder Mediengestaltung, also ich fange selber an, Medien zu formen, also auch das, was im Club immer sehr wichtig ist, Technik nicht als etwas Festes zu begreifen, sondern selber anfangen, die Dinge zu verändern. Und was hatte ich jetzt noch nicht? Medienkunde, Medienkritik, das ist so der Klassiker. Drei von vier gehen immer schnell. Medienkunde, Medienkritik, Mediengestaltung und...
Also es geht aber... Es geht letztlich darum, dass man den bewussten Umgang ermöglicht.
Genau, und das halt auf verschiedenen Formen. Darum geht es letztlich. In modernem Medienkompetenzbegriff wird das Ganze noch erweitert um quasi die mediatisierte Umgebung. Es geht nicht darum, konkret an ein Medium Hand anzulegen, sondern all das, was um mich herum stattfindet, hat ganz viel mit Medien zu tun. Ich muss mich nur in die U-Bahn setzen und verstehe sofort, was mit mediatisierter Umgebung gemeint ist. Ob ich jetzt selber ein Smartphone habe, ist in 2014 total egal, weil das um mich herum permanent stattfindet. Das heißt, das hat auch Einfluss auf mich, wenn ich nicht mich entscheide, in den Wald zu ziehen und mich völlig so was zu entziehen. Also jeder hat mit Medien zu tun, ob man das selber mag oder nicht.
Ich wäre auch in der Fraktion gewesen zu sagen, ja, nein. Und bei mir kommt es manchmal so daher, dass ich denke, wenn wir jetzt Programmieren verpflichtend machen in Schulen oder so, die ja irgendwie auch nicht so der Hort der Kreativität sind, irgendwie dann ereilt Programmieren oder generell so Umgang mit Informatik und Maschinen und Computern irgendwie vielleicht das gleiche Schicksal wie Mathe. Also Mathe müssen alle machen und super viele hassen es. Und ich hab so ein bisschen Schiss, dass das mit Programmieren dann ähnlich verläuft, weil die Leute, die ich kenne, die halt irgendwie Bock haben, einen Terminal aufzumachen und da selber irgendwie Zeilen zu produzieren, die haben halt so eine wahnsinnige Begeisterung irgendwie für Fach und für das, was dahinter steht. Und manchmal denke ich, ertappe ich mich halt bei dem Gedanken so, wenn wir das verpflichtend machen, Programmieren als Schulfach, dann verlieren wir irgendwie ganz viel von dem, was eigentlich spannend daran ist. Weil irgendwer muss es auch noch unterrichten. Das ist noch eine ganz andere Debatte.
Okay, dazu würde ich tatsächlich auch gleich kommen, weil das wirft natürlich jetzt zwei Fragen auf. Die erste ist, wenn man das sagt, dass man sagt, man macht diese Angebote nur für Leute, die eh schon Bock drauf haben, zieht man sich nicht dann so eine Elite dran und ist nicht eigentlich sozusagen die Idee, wenn ich es jetzt richtig verstanden habe, an so einem erweiterten Medienkompetenzbegriff, dass quasi wirklich alle zumindest genug Ahnung haben, dass sie wissen, was die da tun? Und schließt sich das nicht aus, wenn man sagt, man macht das nur für die, die eh Bock drauf haben?
Also aus meiner Jugend hackt Erfahrung würde ich sagen, schließt sich das gar nicht aus, weil wir das, also Jugend hackt ist quasi ein Ferienlager für junge Nerds und spricht die an, die Interesse an Programmieren haben. Die müssen es nicht zwingen können, sondern die müssen halt so eine Begeisterung für die Maschine mitbringen. Und was uns halt ganz viel passiert in meinem Vorfeld von diesen Events, ist, dass Kinder und Jugendliche uns anschreiben und sagen, ich würde total gerne mitmachen, aber ich kann gar nicht programmieren. So, das kann man noch überlegen, ob wir das vielleicht noch, sag ich mal, niedrigschwelliger vermitteln müssen, dass wir uns wirklich über viele freuen. Aber vor allem sehe ich halt, dass es so einen riesigen Bedarf auch gibt, sich eigentlich mit Technik und irgendwie den kleinen Maschinen um sich herum auseinanderzusetzen. Also gerade, das sind halt nicht nur Eltern, die uns anschreiben, sondern das sind halt Kinder und Jugendliche selber, die wahnsinnig Bock haben, mehr über ihre Umgebung zu lernen.
Aber ist das nicht tatsächlich, das ist halt Aufgabe der großen Gemeinschaft, also im Prinzip eine Aufgabe des Schulwesens? Weil, so wie ihr das sagt, es ist ja, und das finde ich nachvollziehbar, es ist halt wichtig, dass das Angebot möglichst breit gestreut wird, dass wirklich jeder die Möglichkeit hat, das zu lernen. Ist das nicht eine Verantwortung der Schulpolitik oder wo auch immer das dann herkommen muss?
Also die Verantwortung sehe ich ganz klar da, weil es schon, so wie Fiona sagt, so ein gewisses Grundverständnis soll halt einfach da sein. Genau wie Lesen, Schreiben und Rechnen oder Mathematik. Dafür geht man ja in die Schule. Und ist halt ein Punkt, der unseren Alltag immer weiter durchdringt. Technische Abläufe, wo auf Programmierung zurückgegriffen wird. Und man sollte schon verstehen, was da abläuft.
Und passiert das denn auch? Also wenn ihr so eine Sache veranstaltet habt, ihr seht nicht auch Kontakt zu pädagogischen Einrichtungen oder zu Leuten, die damit zu tun haben sollten. Ich hab natürlich jetzt das Bild noch im Kopf, Lehrer sind dann eher die alten Leute, die keine Ahnung davon haben.
Genau das ist nicht nur alte Leute. Meist ist die Aussage, die wir bei Vorträgen im Rahmen von Chaos macht Schule bekommen, Ja Kollege XYZ wird ja dann bald pensioniert. Und wir wissen noch nicht, wer sich dann um die IT in unserer Schule kümmert. Wo man eigentlich sagen muss, Oh mein Gott, das darf nicht wahr sein. Das sind Leute, die in meinem Alter sind, also so Anfang bis Mitte 30, wo man eigentlich so ein Digital Native erwartet, der auch ein gewisses Grundverständnis einfach mitbringt für Technik und sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat und keine Angst davor, Technik auch zu benutzen.
Aber das klingt ja zumindest so, als würden die Leute sagen, wir wissen es nicht, aber wir sehen schon ein, dass es wichtig ist. Es gibt ja nun auch Leute, die, also habe ich gehört, auch Forscher sagen so, Technik ist ja generell eher böse und wenn du das anfasst, bevor du 75 bist, dann wirst du total doof und dein Gehirn wird Matsch oder so. Oder gibt es das nicht mehr? Ist es zumindest schon so weit, dass alle einen sehen, ja, das ist was, was wir machen müssen?
Leider wissen wir seit dieser Woche sehr genau, dass das überhaupt nicht so ist. Es ist gar eine Studie, ICILS, die international Schulsysteme miteinander verglichen hat. Und Deutschland hat unfassbar schlecht abgeschnitten. Das ist wirklich bitter.
Letzter Platz, glaube ich, oder? In der Computernutzung im Unterricht.
Genau, und auch was auf die Lehrer bezogen, gibt es quasi in keinem Land so viel Technologieskepsis gegenüber, wie kann man das im Unterricht einsetzen, sollte man überhaupt, wie in Deutschland. Also so für ein Technologieland ist das wirklich ein bitterer Schnitt. Und man muss erstmal strukturell verstehen, wie Bildung in Deutschland funktioniert. Bildung ist Ländersache, das heißt, wir haben schon mal 16 sehr unterschiedliche Bildungssysteme, also Schule müsste mal, ist relativ leicht gesagt, aber wahnsinnig schwer umgesetzt, weil da gibt es natürlich die Kultusministerkonferenz, wo sich alle Länder miteinander austauschen, aber am Ende entscheiden es die Länder selber. Damit gehen schon mal relativ viele Ressourcen in ständig Neuentwicklung und Einzelentwicklung von verschiedenen Themen und man kann nicht einfach als Deutschland, als Bund beschließen, das müsste jetzt mal das Sinn sein. Und dann muss man halt auch gucken, wie könnte sowas an die einzelnen Schüler kommen. Und das funktioniert natürlich nur über die Lehrer. Die Lehrer, wir haben, ich weiß nicht, in Sachsen ist der Altersdurchschnitt bei Lehrern über 50 und da geht es ganz viel in Bundesländern so. Das heißt, das sind Menschen, die haben vor 30, 35 Jahren irgendwann mal ihr Studium abgeschlossen und seitdem im schlechtesten Fall nichts mehr dazugelernt, also natürlich lernen Menschen dazu, aber ich meine strukturiert dazugelernt. Man kann Lehrer auch kaum dazu verpflichten, dass sie sich mit neuen Dingen auseinandersetzen. Da hat man also schon einen riesen Unterschied zwischen dem, was die Schüler können und dem, was die Lehrer können. Medien sind Alltag von Schülern, nicht unbedingt von Lehrern. Und das ist schon auch eine neue Situation für Lehrer, die ein Stück weit ihren Alltag damit bestreiten, dass sie einen Wissensvorsprung haben. Also ich weiß etwas und gebe das an den Schüler weiter. Und das hat sich halt durch Medien komplett umgekehrt. Das macht auch Angst, also da entstehen viele Ängste dabei. Insbesondere älteren Lehrern, die einfach sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, was sie da ist, damit machen, was die können usw. Und die könnten jetzt alles mir vormachen, ich kann das nicht mehr begreifen, ich kann das auch nicht im Griff haben. Und das heißt aber auch in der Konsequenz, wenn wir jetzt das Thema angehen wollen. Also angenommen, wir kriegen jetzt den Beschluss hin, okay, ist total wichtig, wir müssen da was tun. Wir geben 16 Bundesländer an einen Tisch und die sagen alle, ja, okay, wir machen jetzt was anders. Dann fangen die an, ihre Lehrerfortbildung zu ändern und die fangen an, die Ausbildung, also Studien zu verändern. Bis das irgendwie wieder bei Schülern ankommt, also jetzt gehen noch Lehrer aus ihrem Studium, die unterrichten die nächsten 30, 40 Jahre Schüler und die haben immer noch nicht gelernt, wie man medien, digitale Medien im Unterricht einsetzt. Also das ist so...
Da möchte ich mir mal kurz im Kopf fassen.
Ja, da kann ich dem Daniel nur beiflichten, eine Freundin von mir, die vor kurzem verbeamtet worden ist als Lehrerin in Nordrhein-Westfalen, ist teilweise nicht in der Lage, ein digitales Klassenbuch fehlerfrei zu bedienen. Wo ich mir an den Kopf fasse und sage, das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Noch mal zu der Studie, die Daniel eben zitiert hat. Ich glaube, die Co-Autorin dieser Studie wurde diese Woche in einer Zeitung zitiert mit der Aussage, sagen wir mal so, die Studie zeigt, dass in Deutschland Kinder lernen, mit Medien umzugehen, trotz Schule. Und das finde ich irgendwie so hart, dass ich meine, es liegt eine große Verantwortung in so privaten Bildungsinitiativen. Wir sind halt alle aus der Zivilgesellschaft. Ich würde sagen, wir haben auch irgendwie ein gemeinnütziges Interesse und schlachten das jetzt irgendwie nicht ökonomisch aus oder so. Aber das ist schon eine große Verantwortung. Aber ich würde auch sagen, mit all diesen negativen Erfahrungen, die wir mit dem schulischen System in dieser Sache wahrnehmen, sind wir vielleicht besser damit bedient, alternative Lösungen zu finden. Zumal Schule ja auch per Definition noch immer so top down ist. Also da steht halt vorne ein Lehrkörper und bringt dir halt was bei. Und dann soll das Wissen irgendwie so über Osmose in deinen Kopf wandern. Aber ich glaube, dass gerade der Punkt, den Daniel gemacht hat, bei Medien halt so den Ton angibt. Also die Jungen erklären halt den Alten, wie es läuft. Und dieses Kräfteverhältnis müsste man halt eigentlich in diesem Fach total auf den Kopf stellen. Und dazu müsste man Schulen erstmal bewegen, zu sagen, okay, warum machen nicht eigentlich den, warum machen halt die Schüler nicht den Programmier- und den Medienunterricht? Fände ich super, lass uns Modellschulen machen, die das mal so ausprobieren.
Da fehlt, glaube ich, auch ein Stück weit eine Akzeptanz bei den Lehrkörpern, das Heft aus der Hand zu geben und auch mal in die Jugendlichen zu vertrauen.
Ja, aber jetzt muss ich fragen, ob das nicht doch vielleicht eine Milchmedienrechnung ist. Also nicht so eine Art Aufgeben vom System, dass man halt sagt, na gut, wenn die Lehrer, ich sag das mal salopp, zu doof sind, sich das draus zu schaffen, dann müssen es die Schüler halt selber machen. Wäre es nicht eigentlich aber doch die Verpflichtung der Lehrenden, sich auch in diesem Bereich wie in jedem einen Vorsprung zu erarbeiten?
Weil, warum solltest du den Aufwand betreiben und dir einen Wissensvorsprung erarbeiten, wenn man doch Leute im näheren Umfeld hat oder schon Leute an der Schule hat, die das Wissen schon haben, wo man von partizipieren kann?
Na, weil sie, wie bei jedem Wissen sozusagen, also wäre zumindest ein Argument, was man sozusagen bringen könnte, sagen könnte, na ja, das ist halt sagen, wenn sich das jemand reinholt aus purem Interesse ohne sozusagen einen pädagogischen Hintergrund, dann ist das halt was anderes, als wenn sich jemand Gedanken darüber macht und im Rahmen eines ausgerühten Systems halt Medienkompetenz vermittelt.
Na ja, wie man so ein Unterricht aufbauen kann, da kann sich der Lehrer ja dann, sag ich mal, einklinken und seine Stärken zum Vorschein bringen. Also kann man im Grunde genommen zwei Dinge kombinieren. Du hast auf der einen Seite jemanden, der die technischen Aspekte beherrscht und auf der anderen Seite jemanden, der weiß, wie man Inhalte an Menschen vermitteln kann, ja?
Also ich würd sagen Gyeiden. Ich erwarte schon von Lehrern, dass sie ein Stück weit sich mit den Themen beschäftigen, die sehr viel mit Gegenwart und Zukunft von Schülern zu tun haben. Das ist ihr Job. Und dann einfach zu sagen, okay, das hab ich nie gelernt, das ist einfach zu wenig. Gleichzeitig brauchen die natürlich Unterstützung. Das heißt, es braucht Fortbildungsformate, die müssen lernen können, wie man damit umgeht. Und da, glaube ich, wird es dann wieder total spannend, weil da braucht es neue Allianzen. Also die Kompetenzen, die der CCC da mitbringt, die sind natürlich total spannend in Kombination. Also Lehrer zusammenzubringen mit Leuten, die das verstehen und da weiterzukommen. Aber jetzt zu sagen, wir verlassen uns da auf ein komplett ehrenamtliches System, ist viel zu wenig. Wir haben, ich weiß gar nicht, bis zu 11 Millionen Schüler. Das ist eine große Menge an Menschen, die da was lernen müssen. Es gab mal einen schönen Satz von einem Schuhdirektor, der sagte, wir bereiten Schüler nicht auf unsere Vergangenheit, sondern auf deren Zukunft vor. Da steckt zu viel drin an Aufgabe. Und der müssen wir gerecht werden. Dafür braucht es eine Grundbildung Medien. Also Lehrer müssen das lernen. Das geht nicht anders und es gibt auch sonst keinen Job, wo man irgendwann mal ein Studium abgeschossen hat und dann 30 Jahre nichts dazulernen muss. Also das kann man schon erwarten, dass sich Lehrer bestimmte Themen, die wichtig sind, draufarbeiten. Das muss sein.
Ok, ich versuche die erste halbe Stunde mal zusammenzufassen. Es ist wichtig, dass alle, also möglichst alle, den Umgang oder das Verständnis für technische Geräte so erreichen, dass sie zumindest beurteilen können, was sie da überhaupt tun. Keiner schreit.
Gut.
Das pädagogische System in Deutschland könnte mehr machen, als es jetzt tut. Keiner schreit. Sehr gut. Die Art und Weise, wie das passieren muss, darüber sind sich hier nicht alle einig. Gut, dann können wir gleich mal sprechen, was es dann noch an Alternativen gibt. Es gibt auch zwei große Sachen, wo hier bei den Leuten, die sich damit beschäftigen, nicht so große Begeisterung ist. Und ihr seid auch noch aufgerufen anzurufen, wenn ihr euch jetzt angesprochen fühlt. Vielleicht seid ihr selber sogar junger Lehrer und sagt, nein, bei mir ist das voll anders. Ich mache das voll im Unterricht und meine Schule ist total großartig. Ich könnte gerne anrufen 0331 77 97 110. Oder wenn ihr sagt, genau das, was da erzählt wird, nämlich keine Ahnung von irgendwas, so geht es mir auch, könnt ihr auch gerne anrufen. Wir machen jetzt eine kurze Pause, dann gehen wir wieder auf den Verkehr und danach geht es weiter im Chaosradio auf Fritz.
Mit den Highlights aus den besten Konzerten des Jahres. Nächste Woche geht es los. Jennifer Rostock. Und danach geht es weiter weiter. Willkommen im fett Xemba. Die fetten Fritz-Dezember-Konzerte. Immer Montag bis Freitag. Ab 18 Uhr.
In Berlin sollen Flüchtlinge willkommen geheißen werden. Das steht in einer Resolution, die alle Fraktionen heute im Abgeordnetenhaus verabschiedet haben. Verurteilt werden rechtsextreme Kampagnen gegen die Unterbringung von Menschen auf der Flucht. Sorgen von Anwohnern nehme man aber ernst, heißt es weiter. Hintergrund der Resolution sind die Proteste gegen die geplanten Containerdörfer für Flüchtlinge. Aktuell gilt in Berlin ein Aufnahmestopp für Asylbewerber. Grund sind Masern- und Windpockenerkrankungen in mehreren Einrichtungen. In Griechenland haben erneut Zehntausende gegen die Sparpolitik der Regierung protestiert. Das öffentliche Leben war heute weitgehend lahmgelegt. Alle nationalen und internationalen Flüge fielen aus, ebenso Ferien und der öffentliche Nahverkehr. Schulen blieben geschlossen, in den Krankenhäusern gab es nur eine Notversorgung. Griechenland hatte 2010 nur mit einem milliardenschweren Rettungskredit von EU und IWF vor dem Bankrott bewahrt werden können. Im Gegenzug verpflichtete es sich, öffentliche Ausgaben zu reduzieren, Steuern zu erhöhen und mit Reformen die Wirtschaft wettbewerbsfähig zu machen. Schottland soll die Höhe der Einkommens- und Mehrwertsteuer künftig selbst festlegen und die Einnahmen behalten können. Die britische Regierung legte nach dem Sieg der Unabhängigkeitsgegner beim Volksentscheid jetzt entsprechende Pläne vor. Der britische Premierminister Cameron hatte den Schotten kurz vor dem Referendum mehr Kompetenzen und Autonomie versprochen, wenn sie gegen die Abspürpaltung stimmen. Der Gesundheitszustand von Brasiliens Fußballlegende Pelé hat sich offenbar deutlich verschlechtert. Wie das behandelnde Krankenhaus in São Paulo mitteilte, ist der 74-Jährige auf die Intensivstation verlegt worden. Pelé wird wegen einer Harnwegsinfektion behandelt. Von Experten und Kritikern wird Pelé als bester Fußballspieler aller Zeiten bezeichnet.
Das Wetter.
Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin haben wir 2-3 Grad. In Potsdam, Falkensee und Lübbenau sind es 3, Bad Freienwalde 1 Grad. Bis auf minus 2 Grad geht es heute Nacht runter. Es bleibt meist trocken. In Berlin können ein paar Tropfen runterkommen. Und morgen geht es dann ähnlich weiter wie heute, bei 1 bis maximal 4 Grad. Es gibt harmlose Wolkenfelder und vor allem Sonne. Eine Meldung haben wir, die kommt aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin. Die Glienicker Brücke auf der B1 ist bis Montagnachmittag wegen Dreharbeiten voll gesperrt. Bitte weicht über die Nute Schnellstraße aus. Davos geht euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Am Montagabend ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de slash Musikstreams.
Heute mit Markus Richter am Chaosradio in Blumen und das bedeutet natürlich nicht nur mit Markus Richter, sondern auch mit jeder Menge anderer Leute. Das sind im Einzelnen Fiona, Daniel, Maria, Leander und Cebas. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Wir schaffen das bis zwölf noch. Und es geht heute um die Frage, warum nicht eigentlich alle Menschen gleichermaßen über Technik so gut Bescheid wissen, wie die Leute vom, sagen wir, etwas völlig aus der Luft geriffen, Chaos Computer Club. Wir haben heute drüber geredet, warum das eigentlich wichtig ist, weil Technik in unserem Leben drin ist und auf eine Art und Weise, dass man nicht mehr entkommen kann. Und da macht es einfach Sinn zu verstehen, zumindest im Ansatz, was da passiert. Wir haben auch schon festgestellt, dass es, was die Schule angeht, oder das Bildungssystem generell in Deutschland, nicht so gut darum bestellt ist, weil wir, wie war das? Wir sind letzter Platz in irgendeiner internationalen Studie. Was die Rechnernutzung angeht und die Frau, die die Studie mit verfasst hat, hat gemeint, trotz Schule lernen bei uns die Leute, wie sie mit Computern umgehen können. Das ist nicht so toll. Wir wollen dann im späteren Verlauf noch zu den einzelnen Projekten kommen und die vorstellen, die von den Leuten, die heute hier im Studio sind, und das sind echt viele gemacht werden oder mitgemacht wurden. Aber vorher möchte ich noch zwei Fragen zu zwei Projekten stellen, die sich auf den ersten Blick erstmal total super anhören, wo aber die gesammelte anwesende Gästerschaft die Nase grummt und sagt, das ist ja auch nicht so richtig toll. Das eine ist Open Roberta. Das ist was eine Weiterentwicklung, eine Initiative vom Fraunhofer Institut anscheinend, da ist ein Google Logo dran und Lego hat damit was zu tun. Das andere ist, jeder kann programmieren. Das ist von Bitkom, also dem deutschen Branchenverein und vom Bundesministerium für, wie heißt es, Bildung und Forschung. Da würden wir einfach denken, das sind doch jetzt zwei Initiativen, wenn sie Schule nicht schaffen. Diese Initiativen von hochoffizieller Stelle gefördert, mit dickem Geld, das muss doch super sein. Warum ist es das nicht?
Zu Oben Roberta kann ich nicht so viel sagen. Ich hab mir aber die Initiative jeder kann Programmieren lernen ein bisschen angeschaut. Natürlich ist das super, wenn sie einfach eine größere Sichtbarkeit bekommt und ist ja auch ein cooler Slogan. Aber ich glaube, wir müssen ein bisschen aufpassen, wohin das geht. Ich glaube, wir haben schon seit zwei, drei Jahren eine ziemlich präsente Diskussion um das Programmieren lernen. Jeder soll Programmieren lernen. Alle sollen Programmieren können in zehn Jahren. Aber die Frage ist, worum geht es eigentlich dabei? Warum muss jeder Programmieren lernen? Bei jeder kann Programmieren lernen. Es wird ziemlich oft damit argumentiert, wenn du Programmieren lernst, hast du in zehn Jahren einen richtig geilen Job und wirst fett bezahlt. Ist auch ganz cool, ohne Frage. Aber nur allein darum soll es nicht gehen. Vielleicht kann ich noch mal Leander fragen oder ein paar Hörer und Hörerinnen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das so motivierend ist für Jugendliche. Vielleicht doch, ich kann es sich genau einschätzen.
Warte, warte, warte. Ist nicht die Ansage, zehn Jahre und geile Kohle total motivierend, um sich mit Technik zu beschäftigen, ja oder nein?
0331 70 97 110 So Herr Leander, was sagst du?
Ja, also ich würde jetzt sagen, in dem Alter interessiert man sich jetzt noch nicht wirklich für fette Kohle. Also da gibt es eher andere Interessen. Es ist jetzt nicht wirklich motivierend, um sich jetzt mit Technik zu beschäftigen. Für einige Jahre, aber sicherlich nicht für die...
Aber warum würdest du dich damit beschäftigen? Weil du dann wissen willst, wie das funktioniert? Oder was ist für dich ein Antrieb?
Weil ich es interessant finde. Ich find's spannend auch.
Also sagen, eine intrinsische Motivation aus sich selbst heraus. Also der Vorwurf ist sozusagen, dass es möglicherweise in die richtige Richtung geht, aber die falsche Motivation, die falsche Motivation bietet.
Naja, ich frage mich, was wir dann am Ende haben. Also wenn das wirklich zieht und viele Leute fühlen sich dafür motiviert, haben wir am Ende viele, viele Leute, die programmieren lernen, weil sie damit Kohle verdienen wollen. Und ich frage mich, was dann das Ergebnis davon ist. Ob wir dann am Ende total viele Leute haben, die ganz schnell eine Shopping-App programmieren können. Oder ob wir am Ende so etwas wie, ich sag mal, mündige Bürger und Bürgerinnen haben, die sich tatsächlich mit Technik gut auskennen, politische Entscheidungen einordnen, bewerten können und sich vielleicht auch Gedanken darüber machen, was ist denn eigentlich Software, was ist gute Software. Ja, und ich glaube, insofern denke ich, es ist natürlich schön, dass es so eine Initiative gibt, aber wir müssen darauf achten, dass das Feld divers bleibt und dass es auch andere Initiativen gibt, dass es andere Motivationen gibt, die wir ansprechen können. Und deswegen gibt es ja auch andere Projekte. Und man muss da ein bisschen Vielfalt bewahren. Und darüber hinaus denke ich auch, hey, cool, dass es die Initiative gibt. Und da steckt bestimmt ganz viel Geld hinter. Aber ich frage mich ernsthaft, ob das der richtige Weg ist oder ob es nicht eigentlich schon total viele Initiativen gibt. Es gibt ja noch viel mehr Projekte als nur die, die wir haben, die echt gut Kohle gebrauchen könnten. Wo Leute bisher ziemlich viel ehrenamtlich arbeiten. Und ich denke, es ist nicht unbedingt so wahnsinnig leicht, in Deutschland Funding oder Unterstützung für so ein Projekt zu bekommen. Das ist eine Menge Arbeit, die man reinstecken muss. Da sind andere Länder auf einem ganz anderen Level schon. Ich denke, ich schaue da zum Beispiel nach Österreich. Da ist es zum Beispiel, gerade gab es eine Initiative, da wurde einfach mal eine Million rausgegeben an verschiedene Initiativen und Projekte. Und da denke ich, schön, wenn es verschiedene Initiativen gibt. Aber lasst uns doch einfach auch schauen, was gibt es denn schon und wie kann man das fördern?
Okay, wenn ich sage, gibt es, erklären wir dann gleich noch quasi. Ich hoffe, ich sage das nicht um 12 immer noch. Okay, gibt es noch etwas zu diesen beiden Sachen?
Ja, ich finde, wir erziehen uns eine Generation ran mit diesen Projekten, die speziell von der Wirtschaft abgerichtet werden, die Anforderungen zu erfüllen, die die Jugendlichen mitbringen sollen und verlieren die Unabhängigkeit.
Jetzt wird es interessant, es hat Thomas angerufen. Thomas kommt aus Berlin-Mitte und gehört zu der Initiative Wiederkampf programmieren. Hallo Thomas.
Ja, hallo, schön guten Abend.
Was genau machst du denn bei dieser Initiative?
Also erstmal hallo auch an die Kollegen von Jugend hackt. Ich glaube, wir verfolgen da sehr ähnliche Ziele. Also mit jeder kann programmieren, wollen wir eigentlich eine starke mediale Aufmerksamkeit für dieses Thema generieren. Wir haben gemerkt, es gibt unheimlich viele Initiativen, wie Jugend hackt und auch ganz viele noch kleinere. Und die sind aber eben alle nicht sichtbar, weil die oft ehrenamtlich betrieben werden von vielen Leuten, die das einfach mit viel Engagement machen. Und wir sehen natürlich auch, dass das Thema gesellschaftlich unheimlich wichtig ist inzwischen, dass viele Jugendliche diese mobilen Geräte, diese neuen Technologien eigentlich nur konsumierend nutzen und dass uns da ein großes Potenzial verloren geht, weil die Kreativität überhaupt nicht eingebracht wird, mit diesen Geräten eben auch wirklich Inhalte zu generieren.
Aber jetzt ist ja der Vorwurf sozusagen an die Initiative, das wird dann zwar gemacht, dass sie damit was erschaffen, aber dass es dann nur aus diesem wirtschaftlichen Blickwinkel betrachtet wird. Also mache eine App, mit der du Geld verdienst und nicht mache eine App, mit der du die Gesellschaft durchleuchten kannst.
Nee, uns ist natürlich klar, dass auch nicht jeder, der jetzt hier auf unsere Website kommt, dort später Informatik studieren wird und dann der nächste Hacker wird, sondern dass sich die Leute überhaupt mit diesem Thema erstmal auseinandergesetzt haben, weil man dann eben auch ein gewisses Grundverständnis für diese Technologien entwickelt. Wenn wir das nämlich nicht tun, dann haben viele andere Sachen, die da momentan betrieben werden, also sowas wie Open Data, Open Government, Citizen Science. Eigentlich keinen Sinn, wenn da draußen keine Menschen sind, die mit diesen Daten irgendwas anfangen können. Und da ist es natürlich wichtig, dass wir genau mündige Bürger haben, die eben auch wissen, was mit ihren mobilen Geräten, was mit diesen Technologien passiert, wenn man sie benutzt. Die zum Beispiel auch wissen, ob die Daten auf ihrem Handy gespeichert sind oder ob die irgendwo in der Cloud gespeichert sind. Dass man einfach beim Programmieren eben auch ein gewisses Grundverständnis für die Technologie entwickelt und einfach auch in der modernen Welt im 21. Jahrhundert einfach auch weiß, warum bestimmte Dinge passieren, dass es irgendwo auch bei modernen Produkten alles irgendwo nur eine Folge von irgendwo logischen Abhängigkeiten ist und dass diese Komplexität eigentlich kein Hexenwerk ist, sondern dass das alles logischen Abfolgen folgt.
So, Anwesende, was sagt ihr dazu?
Hallo Thomas, ich würde mich freuen, wenn Jugend hackt auch als Initiative auf jeder kann programmieren aufgelistet würde. Das würde glaube ich den Punkt unterstreichen, dass wir da dieselben Ziele verfolgen. Ich glaube, wir beobachten, glaube ich, jeder kann programmieren gern und freuen uns grundsätzlich über Aufmerksamkeit für Themen rund um digitale Mündigkeit. Aber so richtig wirksam kann man euch glaube ich erst beurteilen, wenn es euch eine Weile gibt. Eine Kampagne ist eben etwas anderes als tatsächlich Programme und Initiativen vor Ort, die Dinge tun. Ich glaube, das ist etwas, was sich hier wahrscheinlich alle Anwesenden wünschen würden, dass eben nicht Geld gesteckt wird in eine Kampagne, sondern Geld gesteckt wird in Projekte, die funktionieren, die überlaufen werden, weil die Nachfrage so groß ist und offensichtlich irgendetwas sehr gut funktioniert und diese in die Breite getragen werden können. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was diese Projekttite ist, ist etwas, was das Feld nicht irgendwie nach vorne bringt.
Ja, also wir stehen natürlich auch noch ganz am Anfang unserer Initiative und wir wollen eben genau auch dieses Thema programmieren lernen, eben nicht neu erfinden, sondern einen Einstieg bieten für Leute, die sich mit dem Thema überhaupt noch nicht beschäftigt haben, um sie dann möglichst schnell in eine der vielen existierenden Initiativen zu bringen, dass man irgendwann als Jugendlicher eben sagen kann, ich bin so und so alt, ich wohne dort und dort. Was gibt es hier in meiner Nähe an Initiativen, wo kann ich hingehen und quasi mit Gleichgesinnten programmieren lernen, weil es macht viel mehr Spaß, da hat man viel mehr Erfolgserlebnisse. Die Initiativen, die es schon gibt, die wollen wir natürlich alle mit einbinden. Da wird ein zentraler Zugang geschaffen, dass jemand, der sich jetzt für dieses Thema interessiert, einfach weiß, wo er hingehen kann und gleich Gesinnte treffen kann.
Ich hau mal eine steile These raus. Ich glaube, Coden ohne herausgebildete Ethik ist relativ wertlos, außer für wirtschaftliche Verwertung.
Vielen Dank für diese Aussage, vielen Dank.
Ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, worum es uns geht, das gesellschaftlich einzubetten. Das Netz ist Lebensraum für viele, das Netz ist Demokratie. Das, was wir da tun, ist ein gesellschaftlicher Aufsager. Da geht es nicht um Coding Monkeys rauszubilden, die in der Wirtschaft später gut arbeiten können, sondern die Ethik herum. Das ist der Punkt, den wir versuchen zu fördern. Und in so einem gesellschaftlichen Kontext muss es eingebettet sein.
Kann ich auch nur unterstreichen. Das ist uns natürlich auch wichtig, dass es nicht nur um das reine Programmieren geht, sondern eben genau um diese digitale Mündigkeit. Dass einfach Leute werden, die später mit diesen Technologien umgehen können und auch wissen, was im Hintergrund passiert. Und dass sie quasi auch ihre Daten und ihre Geräte kontrollieren können und nicht von ihren Smartphones kontrolliert werden.
Das scheint mir aber so, als ob ihr euch zumindest jetzt hier auf der Antenne eigentlich doch einig seid. Vielleicht kann man den Rest der Diskussion, den werden wir sicherlich heute hier nicht klären, also der Kontakt ist hier hergestellt, vielleicht kann man sich noch mal zusammensetzen und vielleicht kommt dabei ja wirklich was rum. Oder vielleicht doch nicht. Thomas, auf jeden Fall dir vielen Dank. Also fürs Mithören den spontanen Rückruf auf und viel Spaß. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was dabei rauskommt. Ist ja wirklich sehr spannend, dass dann auch gleich die fastenden Leute anrufen. Das war Thomas von Jeder kann programmieren. Wir wollen ja heute noch die anderen Projekte vorstellen. Da kommen wir auch gleich zu. Jetzt haben wir noch den Paul angerufen. Paul ist 20, kommt aus Verlottenburg, ist Informatikstudent und will nochmal was sagen zu dem Thema. Sollen jetzt Lehrer an der Schule eigentlich Dinge tun? Hallo Paul.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ja, richtig, weil die Diskussion ging vor ein bisschen. Schüler bringen sollen den Lehrern was beibringen. Das bezweifle ich, dass das funktioniert, weil da ich ja gerade in diesem Bereich bin, das studiere, meine ich mich damit ganz gut auszukennen. Und ich würde sagen, 5%, wenn das nicht zu hoch gegriffen ist, der Schüler kennen sich gut genug, sicher genug mit der Technik aus. Ich würde das grob zu sagen, das ist alles so ein bisschen Larifari, wie die Technik im Moment von Schülern und Lehrern genutzt wird. Es sollten beide Parteien unterrichtet werden und geschult werden. Ich habe sehr viele Leute in meinem Umfeld, die nicht mit Rechnern oder nicht mit Smartphones und sich im Internet bewegen, die kennen sich einfach nicht damit aus. Ein paar wurden schon ausgeraubt, weil sie falsch Onlinebanking betrieben haben und so weiter. Das sollte von Grund auf wann geschult werden. Das ist natürlich ein ganz anderes Thema, wie das dann umgesetzt werden kann, weil wir haben die Lehrkräfte nicht dafür, keiner wird da wirklich ausgebildet, das zu tun und da bleiben die Schüler und dann künftigen Leute auf der Strecke in diesem Thema Sicherheit und im Netz. Und da bin ich der Meinung, dass dieses Projekt, jeder kann programmieren, von Jugend hackt, gut ist für die Leute, die es dann interessieren daran. Aber es trifft nicht die breite Masse. Also die Masse, die dann wirklich übers Kreuz gejagt wird, unsicher im Netz unterwegs ist oder einfach nicht mit den Geräten umgehen kann, die bleiben auf der Strecke. Die werden sich auch niemand für Jugend hackt interessieren.
Du siehst aber, dass man doch den Lehrkörper oder das pädagogische System in die Pflicht nehmen müsste und sagen müsste, das muss da geleistet werden.
Auf jeden Fall, es muss extreme Schulungen geben. Ich kenne das nur aus meiner Schulzeit, das ist noch nicht so lange her. Es war einfach abnormal, wie da mit Technik umgegangen wird. Da steht der alte Rechner in der Ecke und das war's. Jeder Drittklässer rennt heutzutage mit dem Smartphone rum. Dann kommt die Banking App, okay kein Drittklässer hat einen Bankingkonto. Aber wenn es Richtung 18 geht, haben sie keine Sicherungen auf den Smartphones, Tams werden abgefangen und Konto ist leer. Da muss es auf jeden Fall extreme Schulungen geben. Und ich finde das Projekt an sich einen sehr guten Einstieg für die Leute, die sich da interessieren oder Interesse geweckt wurden. Auf gar kein Thema, das ist sehr schön. Aber es trifft einfach nicht die breite Masse.
Okay, und für die muss es vielleicht noch mal was anderes geben. So, nochmal kurz, weil die Verwundungen gerade anscheinend, also jeder kann programmieren und Jugend hackt, ist nicht dasselbe Projekt, sondern es sind zwei unterschiedliche Projekte. Man könnte sogar sagen, das eine kritisiert das andere. Und das eine haben wir schon vorgestellt, das andere machen wir noch. Ich würde jetzt gerne kurz mit Leander sprechen. Leander ist wie gesagt 12, geht noch zur Schule. Irgendeiner hat mich vorher falsch informiert. Okay, Leander ist 13 und die hat beides mitgemacht. Du hast Informatikunterricht in der Schule gehabt und du hast bei etwas mitgemacht, dass sowohl von den Menschen, die hier im Studio sind, gut gelitten wird, wie hab ich zumindest Eindruck, als auch auf der Seite jeder kann programmieren steht, nämlich der CoderDojo. Kannst du kurz erklären, was der CoderDojo ist und was du da gemacht hast?
Ja, also der CoderDojo, da sind wir bis zwölf, dreizehn Jahre und jünger, meistens.
Was passiert da genau, kommen die in die Schule?
Nein, das ist am Wochenende und da geht man dahin, da muss man ein Laptop mitnehmen und es gibt quasi, wie soll man es nennen?
Du hast ein Laptop, es ist am Wochenende.
Nein, ich meine Erwachsene, die einem helfen, bei der Umsetzung von etwas, was man sich da vorgestellt hat, was man machen könnte.
Also du hast die Idee für ein Programm und die helfen dir dabei, das zu programmieren.
Ja, das ist häufig damit Scratch, weil viele, die meisten, da noch keine Ahnung von Programmieren haben, da hingehen, meistens interessiert sind. Was ist Scratch? Scratch ist eine Programmiersprache, die von MIT entwickelt wurde. Das ist eine vereinfachte Programmiersprache, die ähnlich wie Java ist. Die besteht quasi nur aus Blöcken, die man dann zusammen zieht. Und die machen dann was, das was die Blöcke.
Also im Prinzip so eine Art Baukastensystem. Das heißt, ich kann sagen, wenn grüner Block, dann gelber Block.
Das ist eben auch eine visuelle. Also es gibt immer direkt ein Ergebnis zu sehen.
Und du hast damit auch gearbeitet?
Ja, weil ich hatte vorher noch keine Ahnung vom Programmieren.
Und hast du in der Zeit, das ist ein Wochenende lang, ein paar Stunden oder zwei Tage, oder wie lange geht das?
Nein, das ist ein Tag, einmal im Monat. Und für so zwei, drei Stunden, ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz genau sicher.
Okay, also sagen, es ist nicht so super lange. Hast du denn da ein Programm hingekriegt, was dann auch irgendwas gemacht hat, was du dir erhofft hast?
Ja, also ich bin da ohne Ziel hingegangen. Da in dieser kurzen Zeit schafft man auch nicht viel. Aber ja, ich konnte ja vorher noch nicht programmieren.
Und danach?
Auch nicht wirklich, aber...
Aber ist zumindest was Kleines fertig geworden?
Ja, und auch das ganze Verstanden, wie das beim Programmieren so ungefähr abläuft.
Also was die Grundlagen sind. Hast du denn danach dich weiter mit beschäftigt? Oder war das so, ok, ich hab das jetzt am Wochenende gemacht, und dann ist gut, und jetzt mach ich wieder, keine Ahnung?
Mit Scratch selber? Nein.
Nee, aber generell mit dem Thema Programmieren? Was machst du seitdem? Was hast du dann anderes angefangen?
Ich habe mit einem Buch, also zum Selbstlernen Java angefangen zu lernen. Ja.
Noch eine Frage zu dem CoderDojo, weil du gesagt hast, du hast in den wenigen Stunden zwar nichts wirklich langfristig Praktikables gelernt, aber immerhin sozusagen so Grundlagen. Verglichen zu dem Unterricht, den du in der Schule machst, wie ist der? Also hast du da einen Informatikunterricht, wo man auch Programmieren lernen soll?
Ja, als Wahlpflichtunterricht.
Ja, das heißt?
Ja, dass man...
Man kann das wählen oder was anderes?
Man kann, ja.
Wie viele Leute sind da so?
Die Hälfte deiner Klasse? Also das Interesse für Informatik als Wahlpflichtfach ist ziemlich hoch. Es gibt drei Kurse und die sind alle voll.
Dann war die Frage, wie... Du hast bei dem CoderDojo innerhalb eines Tages zumindest Grundlagen gelernt, wie das so im Prinzip funktioniert. Wenn du das mit dem Informatikunterricht vergleichst, ist der besser, schlechter, anders?
Ich würde sagen, das CoderDojo ist besser.
Weil?
Weil Scratch ist jetzt nichts Langfristiges, was man langfristig macht. Es ist ein Einstieg. Und wenn man das jetzt acht Wochen macht, dann führt das einen jetzt nicht sonderlich viel weiter.
Und das ist das, was ich bei Informatikunterricht mache? Mehrere Wochen lang dieses Einzige? Ein kurzer Einblick in das Schulwesen der Informatik. Vielen Dank, Leander. Und dann haben wir noch Florian am Telefon. Auch vom Chaos Computer Club. Der etwas zu Mädchen sagen will, die was mit IT machen wollen. Hallo Florian.
Hi, guten Abend.
Der Mutags hier. Also 0, 5% der Mädchen wollen oder können sich vorstellen, was mit IT zu machen.
Das ist schon irgendwie ein bisschen peinlich, oder?
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist keine große Zahl, aber die Frage ist peinlich, wenn es im Vergleich zu Jungs so viel weniger ist.
Das war glaube ich nicht so viel weniger.
Das war glaube ich dieselbe Studie, die vorhin schon ein paar Mal zitiert wurde.
Aber was mir halt auffällt ist, in dieser ganzen Diskussion haben wir es relativ eindimensional oder vom Gefühl her wird da viel in den Topf geworfen. Für mich ist dieses ganze Thema eigentlich in drei Richtungen aufgespannt. Das eine ist so die grundlegenden technischen Fertigkeiten und Kenntnisse zu lernen, also das Programmieren und das zu verstehen, wie so ein Computer funktioniert. Dann haben wir das, was heute eigentlich ein Formatikunterricht häufig noch ist, oder was auch ich so erlebt habe, man lernt Klickstrecken durch Excel oder man lernt dann speziell Word zu bedienen, was sicherlich auch wichtig ist, aber man lernt halt nicht generell Textverarbeitung oder die Prinzipien dahinter. Ich hab nie gelernt, wie man vernünftig ein Dokument so macht, dass es ordentlich formatiert ist mit Formatvorlagen oder sowas. Und das dritte, was wir gerade die ganze Zeit auch diskutieren, ist ja diese Medienkompetenz. Für mich sind das so drei Dimensionen von einem Problem. Und die müsste man eigentlich auch ein bisschen getrennt angehen. Das eine ist natürlich die Technik. Wir haben unter dem Stichwort Code is Law, was für ihn so ein bisschen anklangt, das Problem. Also, Algorithmen bestimmen unser Leben. Google bestimmt, was wir dann an Suchergebnissen bekommen.
Wir leben dann in unserer Filterwabbel drin.
Und dann haben wir so die Anforderung, dass wir mit dem Rechner umgehen können müssen und Anwendung bedienen können. Und dann haben wir halt diese Medienkonvergenz, dass das alles wie ein Rechner drin ist. Und ich hatte jetzt letzte Woche so ein Filmgespräch mit Schülern. Das war eine Notebook-Klasse angeblich. Da sind dann trotzdem irgendwie von 55 Leuten 40 rausgegangen, weil sie keinen Bock drauf hatten. Wo es dann so ums Thema Hacking ging. Also, die Schüler 10. Klasse konnten sich nicht vorstellen, dass man so 15, 16 Jahre irgendwie vernünftig mit dem Computer umgehen kann. Das war für die überhaupt nicht real.
Was heißt vernünftig mit dem Computer umgehen?
Also, in dem Film ging es darum, eine Hauptfigur, der war so auch 15, 16 oder so was, hat halt irgendwie Labcams von anderen gehackt und dann da irgendwie in ihr Kinderzimmer geguckt. Und für die war vollkommen unvorstellbar, dass jemand in dem Alter so gut mit dem Rechner umgehen kann. Das kam in deren Welt so gar nicht vor. Das fand ich schon irgendwie echt erschreckend.
Und hast du ihnen das ausreden können?
Na ja, die sind dann ja rausgerannt, weil sie keinen Bock auf ein Filmgespräch hatten.
Aber was ist denn jetzt dein Ansatz, wie man das klären könnte? Oder wie man das wissen, dass es doch geht in dem Alter. Oder in welchem Alter auch immer, gut mit Rechner umzugehen, dass es halt funktionieren kann?
Es ist unheimlich schwer.
Es muss natürlich daran setzen, zu sagen, wir müssen irgendwie eine Begeisterung wecken. Das war das, was ich früher so meinte. Dass unheimlich wenige da wirklich Spaß dran entwekeln, weil es kommt halt wirklich nicht vor in der Schule. Wir hatten das damals auch. Ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen länger aus der Schule raus, aber wir haben damals ein Zeit lang versucht, uns ein Reserber zu machen, weil unser Lehrer krank war. Und rückblickend muss ich sagen, was bei sowas fehlt, ist natürlich die Anleitung. Die Motivation war sicherlich da. Aber wenn wir uns das selber beibringen, wir haben ja überhaupt nicht den Background zu verstehen, wie man Sachen vernünftig vermittelt. Und sich das selber beibringen, dann fehlen auch ganz viele Hintergründe. Das kann aber natürlich auch nicht klappen, wenn der Lehrer die Hintergründe nicht hat. Mein damaliger Lehrer meinte, so Tieralgorithmen müssen wir nicht besprechen, weil die Rechnung heute so schnell ist, dass was egal ist, welches man benutzt.
Die Ansage ist aber auch bei dir zu sagen, man braucht mehr, aber es ist noch ein bisschen unklar, was.
Ja, man braucht vor allem Schulung und die Lehrer brauchen Hilfe. Die Lehrer, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, waren vollkommen verzweifelt und wussten selber nicht, an wen sie sich wenden können, wenn sie Fragen haben. Und das sind dann solche Fragen wie, naja, die Schüler fragen mich, welche von diesen Chat-Applikationen, wie WhatsApp und Co.
ist mir sicher?
Wie soll ich das denn rauskriegen? Wie kann ich das bewerben?
Wer kann mir das denn sagen?
Und das sind Fragen, wo die natürlich eigentlich an der Realität von den Schülern dran sein müssten, aber selber keinen Ansprechpartner haben und alleine gelassen werden.
Na ja, vielleicht können ja sozusagen die Leute helfen, die hier noch im Studio sind. Florian, vielen Dank dir! Also große Einigkeit auf jeden Fall dafür, es muss besser werden. Und wir kommen jetzt gleich, aber jetzt wirklich gleich dazu, was denn die Projekte machen, wo die Leute heute hier im Studio sind.
Fritz Zwei Sprechstunden.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur zweiten Hälfte vom Chaosradio Imblemun auf Fritz, wo es heute mit Menschen aus dem Umfeld des Chaos Computer Club umfällt des Chaos Computer Clubs darum geht, wie man möglicherweise andere Menschen dafür begeistern kann, zu verstehen, wie die Technik funktioniert, die in unser Leben mittlerweile drin ist. Ich heiße herzlich willkommen noch einmal zurück, den Sebas, den Leander, die Maria, den Daniel und die Fiona. Das klingt so ein bisschen, als ob sie alle schon eingeschlafen sind, aber die sehen ein bisschen wacher aus als die anderen. Ja, wir kommen gleich dazu. Wir haben in der ersten Stunde sozusagen, es hat ein bisschen länger gedauert als eigentlich geplant, erst mal geklärt, wie es nicht funktioniert. Also was Medienkompetenz eigentlich ist, nämlich dieses grundlegende Verständnis dafür, was eigentlich die ganze Technik um unser Leben macht. Und das System, wie wir es gerade haben, noch nicht so gut damit funktioniert, wirklich alle Leute darüber zu informieren. Und die Leute, die heute hier sind, das sind Menschen von verschiedenen Unternehmungen, die wir heute mal ein bisschen vorstellen wollen. Die genau sich das zum Ziel gemacht haben. Wir fangen an mit Jugend hackt. Wer von euch übernimmt das denn jetzt? Die Maria, die gerade noch an der Flasche hängt. Wir können jederzeit damit aufhören, so lange genug das. Maria, Jugend hackt. Du bist da die Geschäftsführerin oder wie heißt das?
Nee, das heißt Projektleiterin würde ich sagen. Ich mache das aber gleichberechtigt mit Daniel, der neben mir sitzt. Und Fiona war super viel in die Orga eingebunden dieses Jahr. Und wie ich vorhin auch schon sagte, ein paar andere Leute. Vor allem viele, viele Mentoren und ehrenamtliche Helfer. Und die Idee von Jugend hackt ist eigentlich aus so einer Not geboren. Wir haben irgendwie festgestellt, es gibt Jugend musiziert, Jugend forscht. Es gibt glaube ich in Deutschland Jugend debattiert und Jugend tanzt. Und es gibt irgendwie diese ganzen Nachwuchsprogramme für junge Talente. Aber es gibt eigentlich nichts, was junge Programmiertalente fördert. Und insbesondere eigentlich diejenigen im Regen stehen lässt, die sich so im Kinderzimmer selber wissendrauf helfen. Wir nennen die so ein bisschen behelfsmäßig Kinderzimmerprogrammierer. Also all die Kinder und Jugendlichen, die sich quasi ungefragt, unangeleitet, auch völlig unabhängig von der Schule, selber die Welt hinter einem Bildschirm irgendwie erschließen. Und so ist dann die Idee entstanden, einen Jugend hackt zu machen. Also ein Förderprogramm für junge programmierbegeisterte Menschen zwischen 12 und 18.
Also ein Programmierprojekt zwischen, das kann ja alles sein, eine Webseite, wo man Programmieren lernen kann.
Nee, das ist kein Tutorial in dem Sinne, sondern das ist tatsächlich ein physisches Treffen. Wir haben das bisher jedes Jahr einmal gemacht, also 2013 begonnen, wir laden Jugendliche zwischen 12 und 18 aus ganz Deutschland für ein Wochenende nach Berlin ein und dort entwickeln sie eigenständige Software und Hardware-Produkte. Also zum Beispiel hat dieses Jahr eine Gruppe namens Awareness mit dem 3D-Drucker ein Armband ausgedruckt und darauf, ich glaube mit Python, eine Software draufgeholfen, die das Armband zum Vibrieren bringt, wann immer eine Überwachungskamera in der Nähe ist. Das war zum Beispiel eins von den ganz vielen Produkten, die an dem Wochenende entstanden sind.
Aber kommen die Leute dann an und sagen so hier, wir wollen jetzt ein Armband mit Überwachungskameras machen oder ist das eher so, da kommen Leute dann sagen, wir wollen irgendwas machen?
Ich glaube, dieses Jahr waren 120 Jugendliche da an dem Wochenende. Es kommen sicher einige schon mit einer Idee, weil die zum Teil auch zum zweiten Jahr eben schon wieder gekommen sind oder im Jahr von Jugendheit gehört haben und schon wissen, was sie erwartet. Also, dass wir ihnen nicht Aufgaben geben, sondern nur das passiert, was sie selber machen. Und ganz viele wissen, sie wollen irgendwas machen mit ihren Fähigkeiten und haben auch Bock irgendwie andere Gleichgesinnte kennenzulernen, aber wissen nicht, was. Und wir moderieren diesen Ideenprozess. Also wir helfen ihnen dabei, eine Idee zu finden, die man auch an einem Wochenende umsetzen kann. Aber was es genau ist, denken die Jugendlichen sich ganz alleine aus. Und wir haben nur so Themenvorschläge gemacht. Wir haben gesagt, hey, ihr könntet euch zum Beispiel zum Thema Überwachung Gedanken machen, was ein großes digitales Thema unserer Zeit ist. Oder ihr könnt euch zum Thema Bildung Gedanken machen. Oder im Bereich Umwelt gibt es auch, sag ich mal, kleine, gibt es Ideen, auf die man schnell kommen kann.
Wie genau läuft das ab? Also, ihr sagt, einmal im Jahr macht ihr das. Da fragt man sich natürlich, warum nicht öfter? Ist das irgendwie so aufwendig, das zu organisieren?
Es ist ziemlich aufwendig. Und vor allem sind wir halt so eine kleine, feine NGO und haben noch nicht das Bildungsministerium im Rücken, um das eben in der Breite aufziehen zu können, wie das der eine Anrufer sich eigentlich eben gewünscht hat. Also das war bisher so eine Mischung aus, wir haben nicht die Ressourcen und vor allem wollten wir auch erstmal probieren, ob es funktioniert. Also ich glaube, das ist auch das, was dem Ganzen so eigentlich den Charme gibt, habe ich so immer den Eindruck, dass wir erstmal gucken wollten, gibt es überhaupt so jungen Hackerinnen und jungen Hacker, also identifizieren, die sich mit diesem Begriff Jugend hackt oder denken die, das sind alles irgendwie die bösen Menschen, als die sie in den Medien immer dargestellt werden. Und nachdem wir jetzt zweimal so überlaufen worden sind, können wir sagen, ja, diese jungen Leute gibt es und sie haben wahnsinnig Bedarf an Förderung und Vernetzung. Aber das wollten wir erst mal rausfinden, bevor wir jetzt irgendwie riesig was aufziehen und dann irgendwie den Teilnehmern hinterherlaufen müssen, dass sie doch bitte bei uns mitmachen.
Wo kommen die denn her sozusagen? Kommen die selber zu euch ran und sagen, wir wollen da mitmachen? Oder werden die von den Eltern angemeldet?
Die allerwenigsten von den Eltern. Und dann schreiben wir auch immer eine nette Mail zurück, dass wir uns auch freuen, wenn die Kinder sich selber anmelden. Weil die sollen ja selber Interesse daran haben und teilnehmen. Und das ist ja eben keine Pflichtveranstaltung. Aber tatsächlich kommen die irgendwie so zu uns. Also die finden diese Webseite. Und dann melden die sich an und kommen aus ganz Deutschland.
Und wie läuft das dann genau ab? Also sitzt ihr dann in einer Turnhalle, wo für das Wochenende irgendwie Stühle aufgebaut wurden? Oder was passiert da?
Also es ist ein Hackathon, so vom Grundformat. Und was uns halt wichtig ist, das so anzupassen, dass wirklich die Jugendlichen selbst davor kommen. Das heißt, wir legen sehr viel Wert auf, dass die Jugendlichen erst mal ihre eigene Ideen entwickeln können und zwar gemeinsam. Also wir wollen da auch nicht, dass die Kids für sich allein programmieren. Das ist nämlich genau das, was sie von der Veranstaltung erwarten. Die sind ganz oft zu Hause und kommen dann auf die Veranstaltung und sagen sowas wie, wow ist das toll, da gibt es noch mehr, die so sind wie ich.
Ein vielgehörter Satz ist immer, endlich unter normalen Leuten.
Genau, also die wissen schon zu schätzen, ich lerne da noch mal Leute kennen, die ich vielleicht zu Hause in meinem Dorf so nicht habe in meiner Umgebung oder übers Netz oder so. Und dann fangen die an, gemeinsam Ideen zu entwickeln, kommen schon mit einzelnen Ideen, werfen die zusammen, verbessern die. Da geht schon mal viel Zeit rein. Dieses Jahr hatten wir dann auch noch Frank Rieger da, um auch genau nochmal dieses Ethikthema aufzugreifen und auch da nochmal Anschlüsse zu geben. Also wo können sie sich gesellschaftlich auch aufhängen, einbringen und so weiter. Und dann geht es schon ins Programmieren. Also sie werden begleitet von Mentoren. Das heißt, wir haben ganz viele ehrenamtliche Helfer, die verschiedenste Programmiersprachen können. Das heißt, wir versuchen da auch ein breites Feld abzudecken, um möglichst gute Unterstützung geben zu können. Und es geht aber dann wirklich um Unterstützung. Die Kids machen selber, die Jugendlichen. Und die Mentoren helfen eben an den Stellen, wo sie Infos brauchen. Oder wie strukturiere ich Code wie...
Das stellt mich schwierig vor. Ich komme jetzt dahin, so programmieren, 3D-Drucker, geil. Ethikvortrag, was... Wie packt ihr das ein, dass das klappt? Oder ist das jetzt sozusagen nur meine zynische Vorstellung von einem Menschen, die nichts über Ethik wissen wollen?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich deine zynische Vorstellung. Oh nein! Wir haben... Ja, man geht ganz optimistisch aus dem Wochenende raus. Das ist wirklich überhaupt nichts für Dystopiker. Wir haben diesen Ethiktrack irgendwie eingebaut auf Wunsch der Jugendlichen aus dem letzten Jahr. Die haben gesagt, das sei alles echt total super, aber wir würden eigentlich gerne noch viel mehr lernen und viel mehr Vortrag eigentlich bekommen. Und dann kam die Idee drauf, weil Frank Rieger, der Sprecher vom Chaos Computer Club, sowas auch unterstützt und gerne tut, den einzuladen und ihn über die Hackerethik sprechen zu lassen und tatsächlich durfte er nicht gehen. Er wurde von den Jugendlichen noch auf der Bühne belagert. Und da muss ich dich wirklich enttäuschen.
Na gut, das ist eine Enttäuschung, die ich vielleicht gerade noch so hinnehmen kann. Und sind die Ergebnisse wirklich alle so brauchbar, wie das, was ihr gerade beschrieben habt, also diese Armband, was die Verwachungskameras waren? Oder ist das auch gar nicht das Ziel, dass da was rumkommt, wo man dann sagt, ein fertiges Produkt?
Also so ein Hackerson ist natürlich so ein Stück weit produktorientiert. Das heißt, da kommen Prototypen raus, die zumindest eine großartige Idee beinhalten. Also brauchbar ist da auf jeden Fall alles, weil da haben sich ja mehrere Menschen entschieden, über ein Wochenende ein Ziel zu verfolgen und da Herzbrut reinzustecken und ihr Know-how. Und dann gibt es natürlich Awareness, dass es super kommunizierbar ist, was man dann auch öffentlich in der Presse sieht, was einfach so ein gesellschaftliches Thema aufgreift. Aber da gibt es auch andere Projekte, die sich ganz stark mit den Themen der Jugendlichen selbst beschäftigen oder Gesundheitsthemen aufgreifen, die gar nicht so schlecht besucht waren, wo wir dachten, so ja, das nehmen wir mal als Thema mit rein, weil das ist auch ein gesellschaftliches Thema. Und dann wird das mit Leben gefüllt. Also da gab es sehr viele sehr spannende. Und vor allem, es kommt halt immer von den Jugendlichen. Also da gibt es so viele schöne Ideen, auf die würden wir als Erwachsene nie kommen. Also das ist da die große Chance, einfach mal einen Freiraum zu geben. Worauf habt ihr denn Bock?
Gibt es da Kontakt zu den Erziehungsberechtigten, nenne ich sie jetzt mal? Wenn ja, was sagen die dazu? Oder was sind generell Reaktionen von anderen Leuten, die nicht konkret in dem Programm selber beteiligt waren?
Die manche Eltern bringen, gerade wenn die Kinder noch kleiner sind, die dann tatsächlich bis zu dem Veranstaltungsort nach Berlin und denen dann da so ein bisschen rum und fragen dann auch, was macht ihr denn hier? Und wir haben auch so eine FAQ-Session auf der Webseite, wo wir zum Beispiel für Eltern die Frage beantworten, kommt mein Kind irgendwie als böse Hacker aus dem Wochenende? Weil das fragen die nicht so explizit, aber die, ich würde sagen, es gibt so zwei Kategorien von Eltern, vielleicht drei, vielleicht eine Kategorie, die sich gar nicht so wirklich für die Kinder interessiert, also mit denen wir gar keinen Kontakt haben, vielleicht weil die Kinder auch einfach autonom sind so und die Eltern denen das zutrauen. Die zweite Kategorie ist wirklich dankbar, dass es Angebot gibt, dass mit ihren Kindern etwas anfangen kann, weil das natürlich meistens eher Kinder sind, die den Eltern so wissensmäßig schon lange davon galoppiert sind und sie froh sind, dass es eine Möglichkeit gibt für das Kind, auf andere Gleichgesinnte zu treffen. Und die dritte Kategorie, würde ich sagen, sind eben so die Skeptiker, die sagen, was macht ihr denn hier genau? Das sind auch die, die dann am Freitagabend, also am ersten Tag der Veranstaltung, dann immer noch so ein bisschen da rumlungern und gucken, ob das denn hier alles zu seinen rechten Gang geht und die dann das aufgegeben haben, dieses Kind irgendwie noch nach Hause zu bewegen. Also für die, das sehr gut ist, dass sie vor Ort sind, weil sie halt sehen, dass produktive Dinge passieren.
Jetzt war das irgendwie im September diesen Jahres, wann ist das nächste?
Ja, das debattieren wir gerade. Wir würden gerne für 2015 nicht mehr immer nur diese einmal im Jahr Veranstaltungen machen, weil das eben viel zu wenig ist. Und wir überlegen gerade, das in mehreren Regionen Deutschlands aufzuziehen. Und das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen von der Geldfrage abhängig. Wie viele Sponsoren wir finden und andere Institutionen, die das bereit sind zu fördern. Denn wir versuchen schon zum Beispiel den Kindern die Reisekosten zu finanzieren. Sie müssen ja auch übernachten, also es soll schon etwas niedrigschwellig sein und nicht etwas, wo nur Kinder mit Geld eben teilnehmen können.
Ist das eben so, dass die jetzt sagen, also klar irgendwie Geld haben wir schon, ist es auch so, dass ihr Leute sucht, die sagen, ok, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist keine Ahnung, bei mir in der Stadt zu organisieren oder sowas. Oder ist das schon eher so, dass ihr das selber machen wollt?
Also damit steht und fällt das Ganze mit den Leuten, die die Struktur geben, die das organisieren, die da ihr Herzblut reinstecken. Und das ist schon auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Also man kann sowas wie Jugend hacken nicht mit Geld lösen. Also das ist ein Teil davon. Aber ein ganz wichtiger ist, das an einer Tech-NGO anzuhängen, die die gesellschaftliche Themen voran zu bringen, vorhand oder das tut, genauso am Clubumfeld anzuhängen, wo einfach engagierte Menschen sind, die da mit dem mit dem mit dem richtigen Fachwissen, aber eben auch mit der richtigen Haltung rangehen. Und letztlich dann auch nochmal die ganzen Prozesse, die da passieren. Also mit Jugendlichen arbeiten ist auch immer ein Fachgebiet. Da gehört ganz viel Didaktik, da gehört ganz viel Pädagogik dazu. Die halten wir auch nicht so hoch, aber die läuft eher so im Hintergrund. Also wie gestaltet man das? Wie kommen Jugendliche gut an? Also krasse Situation. Ich komme da allein an eine fremde Stadt und begegne 120 Menschen als 14-Jähriger. Das ist total krass. Und das irgendwie gut zu gestalten, dass den Kids da auch gut geht und dass die auch gut rausgehen, das gehört auch noch mit dazu. Ich glaube, weil das relativ gut gelungen ist, die letzten zwei Jahre waren das eben auch erfolgreiche Veranstaltungen. Und das müssen wir halt erstmal in anderen Städten auch so hinkriegen. Das heißt, da brauchen wir auf jeden Fall Partner, die Ähnliches leisten können.
Also falls ihr da Lust auf habt, wie ist die URL?
www.jugendhackt.de Kann man sich vielleicht sogar merken.
Sehr gut. Bin ja gespannt, wann das nächste Mal kommt und wie viel das dann sein wird und vor allen Dingen wo überall. Das andere Projekt, was heute auch hier ist, ist Chaos macht Schule. Also kann ich mir schon gut vorstellen, Schule und Chaos passen dann oft gut zusammen, gerade wenn der Lehrer nicht dabei ist, aber vermutlich steckt hier was anderes dahinter. Was genau macht ihr da?
Genau unser Ziel ist im Grunde genommen Medienkompetenz bei Kindern und Jugendlichen zu vermitteln. Und wir versuchen dort mit praktischen Tipps zum Schutz der eigenen Privatsphäre und dem verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit der modernen Informationsgesellschaft zu geben. Da gibt es seit dem Jahr 2006 Projekte im Chaos Computer Club, die erst durch lokale Gruppen in Hamburg und Mannheim unabhängig voneinander unter dem gleichen, zufälliger und lustigerweise unter dem gleichen Namen gestartet sind, ist das Projekt Chaos macht Schule. Und in dem Rahmen gehen wir halt in Schulen, halten dort Vorträge, allerdings nicht nur für Schüler, sondern auch für Lehrkörper und Eltern, um ein Stück weit auch Akzeptanz zu schaffen und die Angst zu nehmen, damit die auch einen Eindruck erhalten, was wir mit den Kindern im Unterricht machen.
Aber wie genau muss ich das vorstellen? Geht ihr da hin, haltet so einen zwei Stunden lang Frontal, Facebook ist böse und dann geht ihr wieder und dann ist alles gut?
Ja, so einen Vortrag halten wir meist für Eltern, so einen Frontalvortrag. Für Kinder halten wir schon einen angepassteren Vortrag, der mehr so in einem Art Workshop stattfindet, dass man mit Kindern auch mal Sicherheitseinstellungen überprüft, also an Beispielen, Profilbeispielen, die man im Vorfeld sich zusammengeklickt hat. Wir entwerfen dann ein Profil, wo wir mit ihnen in die Schule gehen und sagen, schaut mal hier mit ein paar kleinen Veränderungen an dem Profil, könnt ihr eure Privatsphäre schützen, weil soll ja nicht jeder alles über euch wissen.
Wir haben am Anfang gesagt, dass das Horrorbild entworfen ist, das es auch gibt, vom ahnungslosen Lehrkörper. Jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, bei dieser ganzen Medienkompetenzgeschichte, dass das andere Extrem ist, Leute, die ganz selbstverständlich mit dieser Technik umgehen, also das Smartphone, die eine Blackbox in der Hose haben, und das halt irgendwie alles benutzen, aber sich halt irgendwie null dafür interessieren, was eigentlich dahinter steht. Begegnet euch sowas auch, oder ist das wieder nur mal zynischer Geist?
Nein, das ist die bittere Realität. Also sowohl als auch bei den Workshop-Veranstaltungen, die wir für die Kids machen, nehmen die Lehrer auch sehr viel mit. Man hat aber halt oft den Fall, dass Lehrer aus Klassen, die gerade beim Sport sind, oder Lehrer, die gerade frei haben, dann an solchen Veranstaltungen teilnehmen, um ihr vorhandenes Grundbissen noch mal aufzufrischen und zu festigen.
Aber es ging ja gerade um die eher andere Zielgruppe, also die Schüler oder jungen Leute, die unreflektiert damit umgehen.
Ja, die nehmen teilweise auch noch ein Stück mit. Wir haben bei einem Vortrag so ein Beispiel gehabt, der sagt, er kennt sich mit dem ganzen aus und er würde auch sein Profil zeigen und die erste Meldung, die aufpoppte, als er sich dann bei uns am Rechner einloggte, war, dass er einen Urheberrechtverschluss begangen hat, weil er Contentmaterial auf Facebook geteilt hat und das von Facebook entfernt wurde.
Ist das denn mit Wiederwillen, wie die Leute darauf reagieren, wenn ihr den Vortrag haltet, oder nehmen die das dann alles an, was ihr sagt?
Also man sieht schon, dass viele es annehmen. Also viele fühlen sich auch peinlich berührt, wenn sie das erste Mal wirklich erfahren, was sie mit den AGBs abgenickt haben und dass die Informationen, die sie dort selber angeben, auch an dritte Unternehmen weitergegeben werden und im Grunde auch nachvollzogen werden kann, was sie dort machen.
Aber das hört sich jetzt schon noch ein bisschen an, dass Chaos macht Schule, kommt sie rein und macht mir dann eigentlich das Benutzen dieser eigentlich schön bunten Sachen madig. Könnt ihr dann, oder diese Freude an der Technik, kann man die trotzdem noch vermitteln, oder geht immer nur das eine und das andere?
Ja, man muss einen gewissen Zwischenweg finden. Man muss sich halt einfach bewusst sein, Informationen, die man ins Netz stellt, die sind halt erstmal da. Also muss man im Vorfeld überlegen, welche Informationen man ins Netz stellt. Halt einfach erst denken, dann klicken. Und nicht andersrum im Nachhinein. Wir versuchen halt zu sagen, ja nutzt es, es ist da, es gehört zum Alltag ein Stück weit dazu. Aber ihr müsst halt euch auch bewusst sein, dass gewisse Gefahren auf euch zukommen. Dass die Informationen nicht nur für euch lichtbar sind, für eure Freunde, sondern auch für Dritte unbeteiligt im Zweifel. Wenn ihr nicht gewisse Einstellungen halt einfach beachtet und berücksichtigt.
Wie kommt ihr in die Schule? Geht ihr da selber hin und sagt so, hier wir wollen euch jetzt mal was erzählen? Oder kann man euch buchen? Gibt es irgendwo zu sagen, Chaos macht Schule mieten? Zum Anklicken oder wie läuft das?
Nein, man kann über die Seite des Chaos Computer Club halt sich an die Liste melden, eine E-Mail schreiben, was viele Lehrer halt auch machen. Und die erhalten dann von der jeweiligen regionalen Gruppe, die das Thema dann betreut in dem Bereich, eine Antwort. Und es ist so ein Wechselspiel. Es gibt Schulen, die auf uns zukommen und gerne hätten, dass wir vorbeikommen. Allerdings gehen wir auch gerne an Schulen, wo wir im Vorfeld selber Schüler waren und sagen, pass mal auf, wir würden hier gerne euch einen Vortrag anbieten zum Thema Datenschutz, Informationssicherheit, Umgang mit sozialen Netzwerken oder auch mal ein Lötworkshop anbieten. Die Lehrer sind auch sehr aufgeschlossen, dass fachkompetentes Personal kommt und dort Unterstützung bietet.
Das sind also die zwei Projekte, Jugend hackt und Chaos macht Schule. Ich will noch sagen, ihr macht das jetzt, Jugend hackt gab es eben erst zwei Jahre, Chaos macht Schule gibt es schon seit 2006. Habt ihr noch irgendwelche Anekdoten mitgebracht, wo sich sehr schön daran illustriert, was man in so einem Ding erleben kann? Oder geht das einfach nur sozusagen sehr gesellig und seicht vonstatten? Hier wird so geguckt und gegrinsen, das sieht für mich so aus wie, ja, aber dürfen wir das jetzt erzählen?
Ich kann den Tweet nicht, Daniel kann den besser, der mit der sexistischen Sprache bitte, den wünsche ich mir.
Muss ich noch kurz nachdenken.
Ich glaube, das ging so, dass wir haben eben, es gehört auch dazu, dass wir bei der Begrüßung aller Teilnehmer gesagt haben, so eine Sache noch, ihr kommt halt aus verschiedenen Teilen Deutschlands, das heißt, ihr sprecht halt vielleicht auch unterschiedlich und wir haben halt keinen Bock, dass ihr euch gegenseitig über eure Sprache lustig macht oder so, damit wollen wir halt unser Wochenende nicht verbringen. Und natürlich gehört dazu auch irgendwie nicht gegen Mädchen oder Jungen zu schießen, sondern ihr seid alle gleich hier. Und dann gab es offenbar irgendwo eine kleine Projektgruppe, wo der eine irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, seine Geo-Anwendung nicht zum Laufen gekriegt hat und zu seinem Rechner gesagt hat, lokalisier mich endlich, du Bitch. Und dann hat der Kumpel zu ihm gesagt, wir sollen keine sexistische Sprache benutzen, du Arschloch. Und das ist einer meiner persönlichen Lieblinge.
Da war doch irgendwie noch die Geschichte mit dem Sechsklasseadmin, die fand ich auch noch gut.
Ja, wir sind in einer Schule gewesen. Und man hatte uns zugesagt, es gibt halt einen Beamer und einen Mediatorenkoffer. Der wird dann gleich noch von jemandem gebracht. Und dann marschierte ein Sechsklässler mit einem übergroßen Koffer in den Raum rein, wo man sich fragte, ist der Koffer schwerer oder das Kind, das den Koffer trägt. Auf alle Fälle stellte sich dann während des Gesprächs mit dem Jungen heraus, dass er nicht nur diesen Koffer zusammengestellt hat, der an der Schule eingesetzt wird. Also der hat den Laptop ausgewählt, der in dem Koffer verbaut ist, den Beamer und Lautsprechersystem. Und das mit einem Lehrkörper dann zusammengeknubbert, was ich schon sehr bemerkenswert fand und auch toll. Und er erzählte dann so im Beisatz, während er den Rechner hochfuhr und sich einloggte, dass er in seiner Freizeit noch Teile des Schulnetzes halt hier administriert und halt auch so die Netzinfrastruktur und Server halt kennt.
Ich muss noch eine Anekdote zur Jugend hacktlos werden. Ich war ja auch da und ich bin ein riesiger Fan des Projektes und der ganzen Jugendlichen, die da waren. Das muss man auch nochmal echt betonen, dass eigentlich alle Projekte, die dazu stattgefunden haben, entwickelt wurden, haben sehr, sehr wichtige gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen sich angenommen und versucht, Lösungen dafür zu finden. Aber eine Sache, die waren alle total coole Kids. Ich bin ein großer Fan von dem Philipp, den ich den kleinen Professor nenne, der auch eine sehr, sehr coole Anwendung gebaut hatte. Der Vorteil von Frank Rieger, da hat sich ja danach eine total spannende Diskussion entwickelt. Und der meines Wissens 14-jährige Philipp, ich hoffe ich vertue mich nicht, saß im Publikum und hat dann auch ganz viele Fragen gestellt und wörtlich sein Zitat war, also seine Frage war, er fing an mit, ja, hallo Herr Rieger, ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich dran erinnern, aber es gab 2009 eine Folge Chaosradio, in der sie das und das gesagt haben. Also es war erstaunlich.
Chaosradio, das beste Bildungsprogramm, wo gibt?
Und er war damals 9, props an Philipp.
Allerdings.
Das ist eine super Anekdote und ich glaube, generell die Bühnensicherheit hat mich auch ziemlich gefleischt von den Jugendlichen. Sie haben am Sonntag nach zwei ziemlich durchzächten Nächten vor insgesamt 200 Menschen ihre Projekte vorgestellt. Auch mit allen Fehlern und Erfolgen, die man durchlebt, wenn man sich mit Software auseinandersetzt. Ich war generell beeindruckt, wie selbstbewusst diese Jugendlichen sprechen, also gar nicht, was ja auch immer wieder gesagt wird. Die sind so asozial oder nicht sozial kompatibel. Ich fand das komplette Gegenteil war der Fall. Ich fand die Jugendlichen waren auch sehr wach, was Fiona eben gesagt hat, was gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen angeht und haben ihre eigene Rolle auch total gut reflektiert. Am Ende einer Projektpräsentation hat ein Junge, weil dann die Zeit ablief, gesagt, wir wollen dieses Projekt auch kommerzialisieren. Dann waren Daniel und ich schon dabei, das abzumoderieren. Dann hat er sich noch mal das Mikro geben lassen, wo ich schon dachte, so walk on. Ich wollte noch mal sagen, ich war nervös, weil die Zeit abgelaufen ist. Aber selbstverständlich ist das ein Open Source Projekt. Wir glauben an Open Source. Wir finden das großartig, wenn Software offengelegt wird. Ich habe das einfach nur aus Stress gesagt. Der Junge war 15 und hat das beste Open Source Statement. Und hat gesagt, liegt auf GitHub. Das hat uns ziemlich beeindruckt.
Kurzer Anerklärung, GitHub sei eine Webseite, wo man Quellcode hinterlegen kann. So viel zu den beiden Projekten. Fiona, ich würde bei dir gerne noch wissen, du machst diesen Podcast, der auch für Anfänger, vielleicht zur Schaffung von Medienkompetenz dienen kann. Hast du den Eindruck, dass das dafür genutzt wird? Oder ist das so wie bei manchen dieser Sachen, dass es dann halt doch die Leute hören, die eh schon Bescheid wissen, um sich nochmal bestätigen zu lassen, dass sie Bescheid wissen?
Ja, du kennst das wahrscheinlich auch. Es gibt immer auch einen Anteil nostalgischer Hörer, auf jeden Fall, die denken, ach ja, cool, da wird nochmal ein Computer erklärt. Ich weiß allerdings, zum Glück habe ich auch einen relativ guten Resonanzraum, ich kriege auch viel Feedback. Das heißt, ich weiß auch, dass auch die noch was lernen. Aber nein, es gibt auch auf jeden Fall viele Leute, für die das ein sehr niedrigschwertiges Angebot ist, die sich vielleicht für Computer interessieren, aber überhaupt keinen technischen Background haben. Und muss ich auch nochmal sagen, davon gibt es echt viele. Und davon gibt es immer mehr, merklich, auch spätestens seit der Snowden-Affäre, wo Leute anfangen zu denken, ja, ich benutze diesen Computer, der bestimmt eigentlich maßgeblich meinen Tagesablauf und viele andere Aspekte meines Lebens und meines Alltags. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was da passiert. Ich würde es aber gerne lernen. Aber ja, deswegen ist es ja auch gut, wenn die die schwellige Angebote geschaffen werden. Und das bei dem Podcast auf jeden Fall so. Klar, ich freue mich immer über mehr Leute, die überhaupt keine Ahnung haben und den hören. Der ist auf jeden Fall auch für diese Zielgruppe zugeschnitten.
Ist das denn so, dass dann da Fragen beantwortet werden? Oder ist das dann auch so, dass du dann hinterher nochmal so, aber könntest du dann nochmal bitte erklären, dass?
Ja, selbstverständlich sollen Fragen beantwortet werden. Aber meine Aufgabe ist es dann halt immer zu denken, okay, er hat mir jetzt diese Antwort gegeben, wie hätte ich vor drei Jahren darauf reagiert? Wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ich hatte einfach genickt und gesagt, aha, ja, okay, alles klar, ciao. Aber mittlerweile versuche ich dann halt, mich in diese Lage hinein zu versetzen und nachzufragen, ja, hä, was ist denn das überhaupt?
Nee, ich meine sozusagen die Hörer, also wenn Leute, die frisch sind und das gehört haben, stellen die dann noch weitere Fragen an sich oder sind die dann zufrieden und wissen erst mal Bescheid und gehen dann?
Also ich kriege manchmal noch persönlich Nachfragen, dafür gibt es dann auch eine Kommentarfunktion, wo Leute sich nochmal äußern können, je nachdem, aber ich glaube, es ist auch nicht so wahnsinnig zielführend zu sagen, okay, wir schneiden ja dann so eine sehr, sehr allgemeine Frage an wie, was ist ein Internet oder was ist ein Computer und was ist überhaupt dieses Betriebssystem. Darauf wird man keine abschließende Antwort geben können, aber ich glaube, es ist sehr wichtig, sich damit generell mal auseinanderzusetzen. Ich glaube, auch so eine strategische Überforderung ab und zu ist gar nicht so doof. Dann hat man wenigstens ein paar Sachen mal gehört und die Synapses schließen sich halt später. Die Synapses schließen sich später.
Strategische Überforderung, das finde ich ein super Name.
Ich finde auch, aus meiner Sicht, ich habe mit dem ganzen Kram ja erst vor einer Weile angefangen. Ich glaube, das Schöne daran ist gar nicht so sehr, wenn man anfängt, sich mit Computern auseinanderzusetzen. Ich finde jetzt Antworten auf alle meine Fragen, sondern man entdeckt eigentlich erst ein großes, immer größer werdendes Universum voller neuer Fragen.
Oh mein Gott, also wenn ihr überhaupt damit anfangen wollt, dann seid euch gewahrt, dass ihr dann noch mehr Zeit investiert. So, jetzt haben wir euch ein paar Projekte vorgestellt. Wir machen gleich noch ein bisschen weiter hier im Chaos Radio im Domun auf Ritz. Vorher gibt es aber natürlich die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Diese Band ist gerade in aller Munde, weil die machen Bilderbuch im Kopf. Freitag, 20. März. Live im Astra in Friedrichshain.
Solange es noch Karten gibt. Gibt's Karten überall, wo's Karten gibt.
Und das hört man um kurz nach halb nein, um genau halb 12. Oh mein Gott.
Die Finanzierung der Flüchtlingshilfe ist zwischen Bund und Ländern weiter umstritten. Die Länder lehnen es ab, die Unterbringung von Flüchtlingen aus einem Fonds für die Fluthilfe zu zahlen. Das teilte Banenburgs Ministerpräsident Woidke nach einem Sondertreffen der Ministerpräsidenten der Länder mit. Ein weiteres Thema der Konferenz war die Zukunft des Solidaritätszuschlages. Alle Teilnehmer erklärten, dass das Geld aus dem Soli auch über 2019 hinaus gebraucht wird. Die von SPD und Grünen geführten Länder wollen den Soli in die Einkommenssteuer einbauen. Die Unionsministerpräsidenten fordern dagegen eine Sonderabgabe zur Unterstützung wirtschaftlich schwacher Regionen. In Berlin sollen Flüchtlinge willkommen geheißen werden. Das steht in einer Resolution, die alle Fraktionen heute im Abgeordnetenhaus verabschiedet haben. Verurteilt werden rechtsextreme Kampagnen gegen die Unterbringung von Menschen auf der Flucht. Sorgen von Anwohnern nehme man aber ernst, heißt es weiter. Hintergrund der Resolution sind die Proteste gegen die geplanten Containerdörfer für Flüchtlinge. In Griechenland haben erneut Zehntausende gegen die Sparpolitik der Regierung protestiert. Das öffentliche Leben war heute weitgehend lahmgelegt. Alle nationalen und internationalen Flüge fielen aus, ebenso Ferien und der öffentlichen Nahverkehr. Schulen blieben geschlossen, in den Krankenhäusern gab es nur eine Notversorgung. Griechenland hatte 2010 nur mit einem milliardenschweren Rettungskredit von EU und IWF vor dem Bankrott bewahrt werden können. Im Gegenzug verpflichtete es sich unter anderem, öffentliche Ausgaben zu reduzieren. Im Tarifkonflikt mit der Deutschen Bahn will die Eisenbahner Gewerkschaft EVG bis zum 12. Dezember auf Streiks verzichten. Man werde zunächst das umfangreiche Angebot der Bahn prüfen, teilte die EVG mit. In dem Tarifkonflikt streiten sich die EVG und die Gewerkschaft der Lokführer seit Monaten, wer für welche Berufsgruppe die Verhandlungen führen darf. Die Bahn hatte den beiden konkurrierenden Gewerkschaften vor einer Woche ein neues Angebot vorgelegt. Die GDL will morgen weiter darüber verhandeln. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen. In Berlin haben wir 1°C in Marzahn, 2°C sind es in Kreuzberg, Prenzlau 1°C, Cottbus-Küre 2°C und Ciesa 3°C. Bis auf minus 2°C geht es heute Nacht runter, es bleibt meist trocken. Und der morgige Freitag wird dann ähnlich wie heute. Bei 1 bis maximal 4°C gibt es einige harmlose Wolkenfelder und längere sonnige Phasen. Mit einer Meldung aus Brandenburg, Vorsicht auf der A10. Berliner Ring Richtung, äh, nee, 3° Potsdam Richtung 3° Haveland. Zwischen dem 3° Werder und Großkreuz da ist ein kaputter Lkw auf dem rechten Fahrstreifen.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RWB.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt, oder diesen Sound, dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Schöckern. Immer dienstags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de Musik Streams.
Heute Chaosradio im Blumen auf Fritz, das heißt es sind ganz, ganz viele Leute im Studio, nämlich im einzelnen Fiona, Daniel, Maria, Leander und Seba. Salut und guten Abend. Sehr schön. Es geht heute um Medienkompetenzvermittlung, das heißt es geht darum, Menschen dazu zu bringen, sich mit diesem Technikkram auseinanderzusetzen, der unser Leben irgendwie durchzogen hat. Und wir haben festgestellt, es ist an der Schule schwierig, weil die Lehrer das irgendwie nicht können und weil es auch nicht genug Wissen und vielleicht auch Geld gibt. Es gibt so ein paar größere, mit Geld beworfenen Organisationen, wo man so ein bisschen fragen muss, aus welcher Motivation macht ihr das. Und es gibt hier von den Anwesen vorgestellte Projekte, wo man sagen kann, na, da ist vielleicht sozusagen alles irgendwie miteinander verbunden. Und ich wollte jetzt noch eine Frage stellen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, es gibt bei diesem Thema, also Medienkompetenz und Medienpädagogik, wo der Herr Seitz ja heute auch hier herkommt. Und wir kennen uns von, es gibt so Preisverleihung, es gibt so Medienpreise. Da machen halt dann Leute bis zur Altersgruppe XY irgendein Projekt, wo sie unter Beweis stellen, dass sie mit Medien schon umgehen können oder dass andere Menschen werden ausgezeichnet, weil sie halt genau das ermöglichen. Und ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt sozusagen so ein eigenes Subbiotop an Medienpädagogikunternehmen, könnte man fast sagen. Also da gibt es die GMK und ein Medienkulturzentrum und so ganz viele Vereine, die auch immer so einen schönen Namen haben. Und ich frage mich, warum ist das so? Das klingt so, als ob das sozusagen so ganz viele kleine, also wie so eine Art eigene Start-up-Szene, könnte man fast sagen. Also die existiert länger, aber so sagen halt kleine Firmen, die sich irgendwie alle mit demselben Thema beschäftigen. Dann fragt man sich, warum ist das nicht alles eine große Firma und die machen dann was Richtiges. Was ist da los?
Also Bildung ist immer in Deutschland divers und das denke ich total gut so, weil es gibt einfach verschiedenste Zugänge. Bildung ist Ländersache, deswegen verteilt sich das schon mal, hängt an verschiedensten Töpfen, die meisten Medienpädagogik. Institutionen, gemeinnützige Institutionen, Vereine ganz häufig werden durch Jugendtöpfe finanziert in den Ländern, manche durch Kulturtöpfe, aber meistens hängt das an so der Jugendförderung. Und da gibt es eine sehr bunte Landschaft und es gibt die GmK, die Gesellschaft für Medienpädagogik und Kommunikationskultur, das ist, wenn man so mag, der Chaos Computer Club für die Medienpädagogen. Das wird sie sich ja sehr freuen. Da finden viele Medienpädagogen quasi eine Vernetzung, eine Struktur vor, um gemeinsam Lobbyarbeit für Medienpädagogik zu machen, um gemeinsam Sachen zu diskutieren. Unser Kongress heißt Forum Kommunikationskultur, der hat gerade stattgefunden, in der Verein dann so 300-400 Menschen. Das sind unterschiedliche Dimensionen, hat 1000 Mitglieder, ich vermag nicht zu sagen, wie viele da quasi nicht organisiert sind, aber es gibt jetzt auch nicht unendlich viele Medienpädagogen in Deutschland. Um da nochmal kurz meine Ehre wieder herzustellen, Mediennutzung ist der vierte Begriff, den ich vorher nicht parat hatte, weil er halt wahrscheinlich einfach schon so selbstverständlich ist.
Wenn ihr nicht wisst, wovon Daniel gerade redet, dann müsst ihr euch den Podcast zu dieser Sendung anhören, er hat nämlich ganz am Anfang die vier Säulen der Medienkompetenz erklärt. Also er hat die drei erklärt, die eigentlich vier sein sollten. Und das ist jetzt die vierte.
Genau, und nachdem es eben nicht nur um Nutzung geht und wie Sebastian vorhin schon sagte, man das schon beobachten kann, dass man erstmal natürlich Medien stark nutzt, wollen wir eben auch fördern, dass sie kreativ selbst angewandt werden. Und deswegen gibt es auch viele Wettbewerbe, wo wir versuchen, das anzuregen, zu fördern, Kids auf eine Bühne stellen, ihnen eine Möglichkeit geben, ihre Lebenswelt darzustellen, ihre Produktion darzustellen. Da gibt es verschiedenste Medienwettbewerbe, die wirklich fantastisch darstellen, zu was Jugendliche in der Lage sind. Also es gibt ja genug Menschen, die an Jugend zweifeln. Die sollen sich gerne mal mb21.de zum Beispiel anschauen. Da kann man über die letzten 15, 16 Jahre beobachten, was Jugendliche alles aus Medien machen. Da könnten noch viel mehr Coding-Projekte zum Beispiel sein. Da gibt es ganz viel von Animation über Installation, über Medienkunst, da gibt es Webseiten, da gibt es YouTube-Channels. Da gibt es eine ganze Bandbreite, deckt wahrscheinlich noch nicht das ganze Medienhandel von Jugendlichen ab. Es gibt natürlich dann auch noch Filmwettbewerbe, Deutsche Jugend Videopreis und so verschiedene Geschichten, die alle gute Einblicke geben. Eben nicht nur das, was Jugendliche mit Medien tun, sondern auch welche Themen Jugendliche über Medien bearbeiten. Da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, dass es eben im Kern dann doch nicht um das einzelne Medium und das einzelne Stück Technik geht, sondern das, was wir daraus machen und was uns bewegt.
Ich hab immer das Gefühl, wenn man sich das ein bisschen anguckt, dass die Leute, an die es gehen soll, zumindest wenn sie ein Wettbewerb haben, dass sie auch aus einem kleineren Zirkel rekrutiert, als es eigentlich Potenzial hätte.
Ja, klar, es kann immer mehr sein, es deckt aber schon auch ein gutes Spektrum ab. Also bei MBR 20 reichen 1700 Kinder und Jugendliche Produktionen ein, also das ist jetzt auch nicht nichts. Aber natürlich gibt es viel mehr Jugendliche, die etwas tun und die muss man natürlich erst mal erreichen. Und da ist immer die Frage, wer da auch zusammenarbeitet. Also als Pädagogin hat man ja immer ein Ziel, auf das man hinarbeitet. Ich hatte dir das im Vorfeld schon gesagt, mein Ziel hier wäre jetzt nochmal auch quasi Allianzen zu prüfen. Und ich bin total davon überzeugt, dass der Chaos Computer Club und Medienpädagogik unglaublich gut zusammenpassen, weil wir auf vielen Ebenen gemeinsame Ziele verfolgen und jeweils etwas haben, was die anderen nicht haben. Also wir kommen gerade an technologische Grenzen, wo Medienpädagogen nicht mehr alles auf dem Schirm haben. Also wenn es Überwachungsthemen und so weiter. So als Generalist kennt man viele Medien als Medienpädagogen, aber eben dann auch nicht unbedingt eine Tiefe. Ich glaube, da bringt der Club sehr viel.
Wie dann die Strukturen im Hintergrund halt funktionieren, wo wir halt einfach den Bogen schlagen können und euch halt auch unterstützen können, wenn es um die technische Verständlichkeit geht, das halt für Jugendliche oder auch die Eltern aufzubereiten, dass dort halt das Verständnis geweckt wird.
Hey, kennt ihr euch eigentlich?
Ja, seit der Vorbereitung, ja.
Ja, deswegen sind wir ja hier.
Chaosradio bringt Herzen zusammen, sehr schön. Eine andere Frage, also das ist natürlich spannend, eine andere Frage, die ich auch noch stellen möchte, ist, wenn man sich diese Medienpädagogische Unternehmung anguckt, dann, also hab ich zumindest den Eindruck, zum Schluss hängt immer ein Bundesministerium oben dran. Also meistens das Bundesministerium für Familie, Senioren, Frauen und Jugend. Und auch ihr habt glaube ich irgendwann im Verlauf der Sendung gesagt, dass man so einen großen Geldgeber, dass das schon ganz cool wäre und das in der öffentlichen Stelle natürlich auch irgendwie nicht unwahrscheinlich, wenn es um sowas geht, ist denn Medienkompetenzförderung in Deutschland politisch beeinflusst? Also ist das dann irgendwie abhängig davon, wer jetzt irgendwie letzte Wahl gewonnen hat? Oder ist man sich da eigentlich so, ist das eines der wenigen Themen, wo man sich im Großen und Ganzen einig ist, ja, das muss mal so gemacht werden?
Also es gibt immer Strukturförderung und Projektförderung und die Strukturförderung wird mindestens nicht größer, in Teilen wird sie zurückgefahren.
Was ist Strukturförderung für die Leute, die das nicht kennen?
Strukturförderung heißt, dass man quasi, ohne immer wieder neu beantragen zu müssen, Mittel dauerhaft bekommt und damit kann man halt Stellen finanzieren, damit kann man Häuser erhalten, also es gibt in vielen Städten Medienzentren, wo Jugendliche eben hingehen können und mit Medien arbeiten und sowas ist ganz wichtig, um einfach so eine Kontinuität zu gewährleisten und nicht immer wieder Dinge komplett neu zu erfinden. Bei Projektförderung ist es eben so, da muss man tatsächlich...
Also die Strukturförderung ist sozusagen, also so egal, wer jetzt gerade irgendwer da macht, die bricht jetzt nicht irgendwie einen großen Geldtopf aus, aber die kommt zumindest stetig.
Genau und natürlich gibt es da Abstimmung, natürlich gibt es da einen gesellschaftlichen Diskurs, also es ist ja nicht so, dass Politik grundsätzlich mein Gegenüber ist, vor dem ich mich wehren muss, sondern da werden ja auch gesellschaftliche Themen ausgehandelt und das ist erst mal richtig so, aber die Frage ist natürlich immer, bin ich da sehr stark davon abhängig oder gibt es ein Stück weit eine Unabhängigkeit, wo ich eben auch mal Themen behandeln kann, die vielleicht gerade der Staat nicht unbedingt sehen will. Also komme ich wieder auf Überwachung zurück, also da werde ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht bei der Bundesregierung drei Millionen beanzahlen können, um das Thema anzuziehen. Insofern brauchen wir schon ein Stück weit Unabhängigkeit und die findet eben vor allem über dauerhafte Mittel statt und bundeszentrale für politische Bildung würde ich da jetzt noch neben das Bundesfamilienministerium stecken, die auch eben ganz starke Förderer von Medienpädagogik sind und auch quasi schon relativ unabhängig agieren, obwohl sie am Innenministerium hängen, das muss man an der Stelle auch immer wieder sehen, dass wir teilweise auch komische Strukturen haben, wo wir was gesellschaftlich andocken, dennoch schaffen die es auf jeden Fall so ihre Themen zu setzen und da Medienpädagogik zu fördern, wo es auch wichtig ist.
Also wir hatten die Strukturförderung, dann gibt es noch die Projektförderung, ist das da anders?
Also ganz vieles über das Familienministerium zum Beispiel, auch bundeszentrale gibt es einige längere fristige Projekte, aber das meiste sind tatsächlich Projektförderung und das hat aber vor allem damit zu tun, dass Bildung Länderaufsage ist, das heißt eigentlich dürfen die Bundesministerien nur Piloten fördern, also sie können quasi nur neue Themen anstoßen, aber die dauerhafte Förderung, die obliegt den Ländern.
Aber jetzt trotzdem noch zu eigentlichen Fragen zurückzukommen, ist das politisch gefärbt? Also welche Projekte da gefordert werden, also kann man das erkennen?
Kann man ganz klar erkennen, auf jeden Fall.
Man sieht das schon so, wenn man sich ein Stück weit mit dem Thema beschäftigt, dass da schon einige wirtschaftliche Interessen wirklich forciert werden.
Ja, und nicht nur wirtschaftliche Interessen, sondern ganz stark, das fällt auch Kinder- und Jugendmedienschutz, also so Safer Internet und wir laden Kinder dazu ein, eigene Schutz-Apps zu bauen und so, das ist quasi, das ist politisch en vogue und beißt sich, glaube ich, so ein bisschen mit den Projekten, die wir hier auch im Laufe der Sendung so gehört haben, wo es eigentlich eher darum geht, so die Chancen zu betonen und den eigenen Handlungsspielraum zu erweitern und nicht zu verengen, aber zudem, wie sehr man von so einem politischen Farbenwechsel abhängig ist. Ich weiß, dass im Bundesfamilienministerium, ich kann immer nur die Abkürzung und das nicht aussprechen, BMF, SFJ, du kannst das in Gänze. Na jedenfalls, dieses Familienministerium ist ja jetzt irgendwie auch schon seit einem Jahr konstituiert. Letztes Jahr war ja Bundestagswahl und in der Folge sortiert sich so ein Ministerium ja auch immer neu, wenn das gerade eine politische neue Führung bekommt und es gibt dort ein Referat, das heißt Digitales und Medien und wenn man auf das Organigramm von diesem Familienministerium guckt, steht da halt immer noch Endpunkt Endpunkt. Also es ist einfach immer noch nicht besetzt und das ist natürlich schon so ein Zeichen, dass du schon sehen kannst irgendwie vielleicht geht gerade von diesem Ministerium in diesem Bereich nicht der größte Impuls aus, weil wenn es wirklich wichtig wäre, dann hätte man sich darum gekümmert, dass da jemand schon mit Feuer ist und die Projekte die gut sind weiter vorantreibt.
Ja ich finde, es tauchen total viele Beispiele dafür auf, dass also ich fand halt vorhin immer den Aspekt interessant, dass jemand sagte, hey ja aber es ist total wichtig, dass es in der Schule gelehrt wird und dass man das da durchsetzt und das stimmt, dem stimmen wir ja alle zu, aber man kann halt echt nicht darauf warten und ich glaube keiner von uns geht ja hin und sagt allen Leuten, jetzt lernt alle programmieren, aber wir schaffen halt ein Angebot, das es sonst nicht gibt.
Das kann ich nur unterstützen, also ich glaube, das ist halt der Unterschied zu dem, zu dieser Forderung, das muss doch alles in der Schule sein, dass wir einfach schon mal machen. Und natürlich auch ein bisschen das Feld irgendwie.
Wir geben halt Impulse.
Ja, die Verantwortlichen zeigen auch ein Stück weit immer gegenseitig mit den Fingern auf dich. Einmal die Politik sagt oder die übergeordnete Politik sagt, ist Schulsache. Die Schule sagt, ist Elternsache. Die Eltern sagen, ist Schulsache. Das fühlt sich im Grunde genommen keiner verantwortlich für die nächste Generation die Verantwortung zu übernehmen und ein Stück weit anzuleiten, wo es langgeht.
Also müssen es halt Leute machen, die Bock drauf haben. Es ist jetzt auch kein ungewöhnlicher Hergang. Also, dass irgendwie Leute eben nicht aus dem politischen Bereich oder nicht aus dem schulischen Bereich und die generell nicht in Strukturen drin stecken, einfach sagen, jetzt machen wir mal und dann kann das ja im besten Fall rüber schwappen.
So Institutionen wie uns alle, die wir hier versammelt sind, gibt es ja im Grunde genommen nur, weil sich keiner die Verantwortung dafür übernehmen möchte und ich glaube, es würde uns alle sehr begeistern, wenn die Politik dort aktiver wäre und mehr Input liefern würde und mehr Aktivität auch zeigen würde, dass wir uns im Grunde genommen als überflüssig achten können. Das ist eigentlich das Ziel von allen hier am Tisch.
Und vielleicht nicht die 17. Initiative zu gründen, sondern einfach auf die Pferde zu setzen, die schon bewiesen haben, dass es funktioniert.
Na, wir werden sehen, ob das in Zukunft in Erfüllung tritt, ich glaube eher nicht, aber das ist möglicherweise nur meine persönliche Meinung. Und ich möchte zum Schluss noch zu einem ganz konkreten Beispiel kommen. Und zwar ist ja Apropos Chaosradio, Apropos Chaos Computer Club vom 27. bis 30. Dezember wieder der Chaos Communication Congress. Und auch da gibt es ein spezielles Programm für Leute, die noch nicht so doll alt sind. Und da kann Pat uns was genau darüber erzählen. Hallo und guten Abend.
Ja, hallo, hallo, in Studio.
Schönen guten Abend.
Und es gibt da einen sogenannten Junghackertag und du hast da mitgemacht?
Ja, nein.
Nein, ja, nein.
Der Junghackertag ist nicht mein Bereich.
Da kann ich aber dem Pat gerne noch ein paar Informationen zu liefern.
Genau, wir wollten ja Kontakt aufnehmen, hab ich schon gehört.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Ich dachte, wir reden jetzt heute mit dir, damit du uns ein bisschen was über den Junghackertag erzählst.
Ja, ich hab letztes Jahr den Kidspace ins Leben gerufen und da geht's ja um Kinder unter 12, also für die Kleineren. Das geht dann schon so bei ein bis zwei Jahren los und da geht's dann um einmal darum, dass die Eltern und die Kinder eine Möglichkeit haben, ihre Kinder in den Kongress zu integrieren und nicht nur irgendwo abzugeben oder alleine hinzugehen. Und da lässt sich halt auch viel Wissen vermitteln. Das ist natürlich nicht ganz so pädagogisch wie mit den älteren Kindern. Wir machen eher so Sachen, dass wir da so, letztes Jahr hatten wir so einen Workshop mit Little Bits, das sind so kleine Platinen, die man aneinander klicken kann mit Magneten, die sich nicht verpolen lassen und so. Da kann man dann so kleine, ja kleine Geschichten draus bauen, die irgendwie Töne machen und leuchten oder mit Motoren und so weiter und so fort.
Oder ist das dann angenommen worden auch als, hey, das finde ich gut, dass es ihr angenommen worden ist, ja, ich kann meine Kinder hier abwerfen, schnell weg!
Ja, das war es. Also in Berlin war es früher so, dass es halt sehr eng war und wir hatten eigentlich nur so eine Lego-Ecke da und da gab es den Kids-Base halt noch nicht so richtig, da wurden wir viel mit Lego gespielt, auch von den Älteren. Dann gab es noch zwischendurch so einen Raum im Nebenhaus, wo man die Kinder abgeben konnte. Das hat mir jetzt nicht so gefallen, für meine Tochter. Da geht es mehr um Integration. Wir sind da ziemlich zentral eigentlich, direkt vor so einem Hauptsaal, Saal vor Saal 2, nicht vor Saal 1, und in den Foyers und haben da so einen ganzen Bereich, wo wir so ein eigenes Bällebad haben, also ein bisschen für Bewegung sorgen auch und so. Und das wird sehr gut angenommen von den Eltern. Die haben sich alle sehr gefreut, dass ihre Kinder da mitnehmen können und dass die da auch gut aufgehoben sind und auch so ein bisschen Einblick in den Kongress haben, weil das ja eine ganz interessante Szene ist für Kinder, die können halt unwiel sehen und ich persönlich bin Softwareentwickler und bin ganz froh, wenn ich meiner Tochter erklären kann, was ich so mache und das kann man halt nicht immer so gut sehen, aber auf dem Kongress sieht man das ganz gut, was man da mit so machen kann. Und da gibt es halt viele Punkte, die sich echt lohnen, also da die Kinder mitzunehmen. Meine Tochter hat auch einen riesen Spaß und kennt dann zwischen alle und so. Das macht echt, das ist schon ganz gut.
Okay, das ist sozusagen, das ist für die Unterzwölfigen und Leander, der ist ja 13, für den ist dann vielleicht der Jugendhackertag, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Was ist das? Genau, der Jugendhackertag ist am Tag 3, wo Eltern mit ihren Kindern vorbeikommen können, wo ein Elternteil halt freien Eintritt erhält und die Kinder sowieso. Dort gibt es halt Projekte, wo Workshops stattfinden, wo gelötet werden kann, geschraubt werden kann, um ein bisschen so technische Fingerfertigkeiten zu schulen. Einfach vorbeikommen mit dem Kind, sagen wir würden gerne an dem Projekt teilnehmen und dann sofern Kapazitäten da sind, kann man das durchaus machen. Wir hatten im letzten Jahr 80 Jugendliche, die wir an einem Tag betreut haben, die halt gelötet haben. Es gibt so verschiedene Lötaktionen, wie den Penta-Bug, der angeboten wird, der von den Kids gelötet werden kann. Dann so eine kleine Anamalage, die halt mehr zum Schrauben gedacht ist, wo man Phasenprüfer braucht. Und in diesem Jahr wird es etwas Neues geben, wo ich jetzt noch nicht so viel zu verraten möchte, um auch noch die Spannung ein bisschen aufrechtlich zu erhalten.
Ah ja, das heißt, man soll auch wirklich dann zum Kongress kommen?
Ja, selbstverständlich. Also Hamburg ist eine Reise wert, aber der Kongresse ist sowieso eine Reise wert.
Na gut. Dann sehr schön. Pat, an dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und viel Spaß im Bällebad. Ich glaube ja, das ist auch eine von den Kindereinrichtungen, wo die Erwachsenen eigentlich das für sich selbst gemacht haben. Aber gut, so, das Chaosradio geht jetzt bald schon zu Ende. Wir haben noch ein paar Minuten und ich würde sagen, von jedem von euch noch sozusagen, wir es bei diesen großen, mit eben pädagogischen Kongressen auch mal schön gerne gemacht und ein Abschlussstatement haben. Was ist denn jetzt so mit der näheren Zukunft? Was wünscht ihr euch denn jetzt als Nächstes? Fangen wir mal ganz rechts an beim CeBAS.
Ich wünsche mir, dass unsere Projekte überflüssig werden, da die Politik halt die Notwendigkeit erkennt und endlich mal den Ball, den wir versuchen immer zurückzuspielen, aufnimmt und sinnvoll verwertet.
Und wie viel Hoffnung hast du, dass das klappt? Gut, wir belassen das so als Antwort.
Maria?
Ich habe gehofft, dass ich zuletzt erst sprechen muss.
Na gut, Fiona?
Ich hoffe mir schon mehr solcher Projekte, weil ich glaube, es lassen sich Dinge nicht einfach politisch oder mit viel Geld oder sonst wie lösen, sondern es müssen auch die richtigen Leute mit der richtigen Haltung machen. Und deswegen wünsche ich mir eher mehr Projekte, wie Chaos macht Schule, wie Jugend hackt und so weiter, weil Bedarf wird immer da sein, die Themen werden sich verändern, die sind glaube ich da nicht so entscheidend und ich wünsche mir, dass das Ganze nicht nur auf Probleme orientiert ist. Also es geht nicht darum permanent zu vermitteln, was man alles nicht darf und wie schlimm das alles ist, sondern am Ende geht es ein Stück weit um Technik-Faszination, aber es geht auch um die gesellschaftlichen Themen, die dahinterstehen und ich glaube so erreichen wir dann auch alle Jugendlichen, die das erreichen sollten.
Und ich wünsche mir, dass wir vielleicht morgen oder übermorgen einen Anruf aus dem Bildungsministerium bekommen, der sagt, ich habe von Jugendhack gehört im Chaosradio, das ist eine super Sache, wie machen wir das jetzt groß, weil scheiß drauf, dann redet ihr vielleicht auch über den Staatstrojaner und dass das nicht so geil ist, aber da können wir mit umgehen als souveräner Staat. Wir möchten, dass der Ansatz irgendwie vielen, vielen zugänglich wird.
Ja, ich wünsche mir, dass solche Projekte wie von uns oder andere auch strukturell etwas ändern, nämlich, dass sie Leuten die Angst nehmen davor, sich mit Technik auseinanderzusetzen, dass sie Leuten, die Menschen, die sich für Computer interessieren, auch eine Chance geben und viele, viele Möglichkeiten geben, ohne dass da noch Barrieren dazwischen sind. Ja, oder dass sie denken, sie können das ja gar nicht. Daran möchte ich gerne was ändern. Aber natürlich will ich vor allem, dass noch viel, viel mehr Leute das machen, gerne auch besser als wir alle zusammen. Wir wollen ja auch gar nicht arbeiten, wir geben das total gerne ab, wenn es da mehr Leute gibt, die das machen, super cool. Ihr seid alle Hörer und Hörerinnen, sind herzlich dazu aufgerufen und dritte strukturelle Änderung, dass alle Leute, die solche Fähigkeiten besitzen, Bescheid wissen, das auch gerne weitergeben.
So, große Wünsche könnt ihr gerne erfüllen. Ihr könnt einen Anfang machen für Leute, die sich da potenziell für interessieren können, eben den Podcast dieser Sendung weitergeben. Erscheint im Laufe der Nacht noch auf ritz.de, dann später auch irgendwann auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Außerdem soll ich noch sagen, wenn ihr euch für das Projekt Chaos macht Schule interessiert, es gibt an Berlin in jedem ersten Mittwoch des Monats im Chaos Computer Club Berlin ab 20 Uhr ein Treffen. In der Marienstraße 11 ist das. Und falls ihr euch generell für Themen interessiert und denkt, ja dieser Club, vielleicht könnte man da mal gucken, was sie so machen. So ganz vorsichtig. Dienstag und Donnerstag haben die Tag der offenen Tür. Mein Name ist Markus Richter, ich verabschiede mich jetzt auch. Bedanke mich nochmal bei Fiona, Daniel, Maria, Leander und Cebas. Wiedersehen.
Bitte schön.
Und übergebe dann einen Nightfight mit Flo Heiler, der euch, wenn ich es richtig sehe, so wie immer, mit Gitarrenmusik bewerfen wird, bis euch die Ohren bluten. Eine Sache bleibt mir noch zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss!